einem team aber den standort verlassen
weil es zu gefährlich war erstmal die
frage axel können sie mich hören oh
ja ich kann gerade noch mal vielleicht
können sie uns sagen was aktuell
passiert und so sind sie gerade
da wir gehen auf dem weg an einen ort
wie wir glauben dass er häufig
sicherheits und weiterarbeiten zu können
richtig wir haben heute morgen
verlassen die tür stelle am körper lässt
schwere explosionen im
umfeld der stadt die deutlich zu hören
waren und weil wir auch
unser foto klein informanten unsere
ansprechpartner im osten des landes
informationen bekommen haben also wird
wirklich leider not geht wir haben eben
das chinesische außenministerium zitiert
ansonsten stehe das sortieren der
ukraine post anders zu deuten als eine
russische invasion russischer truppen
aufwarten und hob im norden im ort die
uns in zügen und der krim hier
ausschließlich um gefühle geht
mit meldungen über die verführung von
militärische infrastruktur hafen werden
angeboten die standorte der
kampfflugzeuge soll ausgeschaltet werden
also schon einen berg dramatische
szenarien vielleicht können sie uns noch
mal die situation schildern mal wieder
meldungen lesen das haar wirklich zu
dutzenden zu tausenden die menschen kia
verlassen es zu langen staus kommt was
können sie uns darüber berichten
die christlichen kirchen kilometer lange
stau papier daraus
geschäftsführung etwas eingeschränkt
dass eine große verkehrs aber wir haben
vertrauen zwischen war ein kompletter
stopp menschen überlegen sich jetzt in
welche richtung sie auch bei legalen
durch den westen haben das system
gefordert man sozusagen aus norden
kommenden fußball daten werden oder er
sich
das nicht die beiden auch zu diese
stehen an den tankstellen an jeder
tankstelle der anlage stark erhöht wie
üblich aus menschen
ihre autos auf zuzüge geldautomaten
werden belagert ja
ja das ukrainische innenministerium
meldet soeben das kamen gerade sieben
getötete ukrainische soldaten man kann
dies natürlich schlecht und schwer
verifizieren
vielleicht können sie uns noch mal die
situation schildern wohin begeben sie
sich jetzt axel
ja wir machen wirklich gesagt auf dem
weg zu einem ordnen wir in hotelbetten
altwerden halbwegs sicheren
produktion dort dann auch wieder mit
bild mit ihm sprechen kann man mit dem
anderen zdf redaktionen sind auf dem weg
und ja genau was die getöteten soldaten
archiv das kann man in dem moment
natürlich wieder bestätigt noch
dementiert die ukraine meldet auch mal
habe russische kampfjets abgeschauten
kunststück aber
im moment alles noch unklar dazu kann
man eine spieltage dann passen sie bitte
auf sich und das team als alles gute
axel sturm war das aus der ukraine
vielen dank
und diese ereignisse rufen natürlich
reaktionen in jedem land hervor weltweit
herrscht entsetzen die solidarität gilt
natürlich den menschen in der ukraine
die von diesem krieg jetzt betroffen
sind joe biden ein paar stunden zurück
sechs stunden früher ist es jetzt in
washington hat sich noch mitten in der
nacht natürlich auch geäußert davon
gesprochen putin habe den krieg
vorsätzlich begonnen deshalb wollen wir
noch mal nachfragen bei unseren us
korrespondenten in washington almaty
wissen was es aus dem weißen haus zu
hören
ja da konzentriert man sich hier in
washington vor allen dingen auf zwei
punkte das eine ist das was militärisch
gerade tatsächlich in der ukraine
passiert und da hat man gesehen bilder
die mittlerweile vorliegen auch von
unserem partner sein dass hier ein enya
gezeigt werden das russische panzer und
zwar in großer zahl über die grenze
gerollt sind am grenzübergang cent kiss
and kill heißt dieser der liegt im
dreiländereck zwischen belarus russland
und eben der ukraine und diese bilder
würden bedeuten dass diese panzer in
richtung key erfreuen könnte es eine
sehr gut ausgebaute straße und das
pentagon versucht jetzt zu verifizieren
ob tatsächlich russische truppen auf 4
vorrücken man macht sich da große sorgen
denn es könnte sein dass ein teil des
russischen plans wäre das neue kiew
tatsächlich einnimmt und daneben
abschneidet vom kommando über die
truppen im osten der ukraine
das wäre so etwas wie ein
enthauptungsschlag der da stattfinden
könnte das ist jedenfalls die große
sorge des pentagon man prüft momentan
noch sehr genau sind unter diesen
truppen die über die ukrainische grenze
gefahren sind auch belarussische truppen
es gibt einige hinweise darauf dass
würde aber dann bedeuten dass nicht nur
russland sondern auch bela russland sich
in den krieg mit eingeschaltet hat das
ist das eine was man hier in washington
sehr intensiv verfolgt und das zweite
ist natürlich die geschlossenheit zu
demonstrieren und die auch zu halten
wenn es jetzt um sanktionen geht der us
präsident wird beim g7-treffen gleich
mit den anderen anführern der g7
nationen sowie auch beim treffen der
nato verbündeten über diese sanktionen
reden aber man kann ganz klar sagen die
sanktionen liegen seit wochen in der
schublade man hat alles bis ins feinste
detail abgestimmt sie werden sehr
umfangreich sein sie werden russland so
geht man jedenfalls davon aus sehr hart
treffen und man hat auch maßnahmen
ergriffen um die wirkung dieser
sanktionen auf die europäische union
aber auch auf die usa abzufedern ganz
besonders was den energiebereich
antrifft das heißt konkret umwelt was
für sanktionen wird es sich dort handeln
und wieso geht man davon aus dass sie
putin dieses mal hart treffen werden
ja das eine ist man wirft sanktionen
gegen die größten banken gegen die fünf
größten banken russlands verhängen und
das würde bedeuten dass diese banken
nicht mehr in der lage sind sich auf dem
weltmarkt irgendwo geld zu besorgen
dollar möglicherweise transaktionen
durchzuführen
ich will mal ein beispiel nennen die
größte dieser banken ist die sberbank
die alleine ist für die auszahlung der
hälfte aller gehälter und renten in
russland zuständig diese bank quasi
international nicht mehr aktiv sein kann
dann wird das massive auswirkungen in
russland haben die eu hat ja in diese
richtung gerade auch maßnahmen verkündet
der zweite punkt wird sein dass man die
technologien auf die russland angewiesen
ist beispielsweise im rüstungs im
rüstungsbereich oder auch in der
hochtechnologie in russland dass man
diese technologien
exportkontrollen unterziehen wird das
heißt weder die europäische union noch
die usa werden irgendwelche waren und
güter liegen r liefern in denen
westliche technologie steckt sein des
halbleiter mikrochips oder software das
wird die russische wirtschaft treffen
und das dritte und das sicherlich
schärfste schwert sind sanktionen gegen
die energieindustrie russlands russland
ist angewiesen auf gas und öl natürlich
sind die europäer auf gas und öl
angewiesen dass aus russland kommt
russland braucht aber das geld das soll
boykottiert werden geblockt werden und
man hat in den letzten wochen so wie man
die sanktionen erarbeitet hat auch pläne
erarbeitet wie man das abfedern kann
will auch da ein beispiel nennen man hat
einerseits die vorräte aufgestockt
massiv in europa in den usa und anderswo
man hat zweitens lieferungen die für
andere teile der welt gedacht waren zb
für asien die hat man umgeleitet nach
europa in den letzten wochen und das
dritte mann hat mit anderen
gaslieferanten gesprochen alle vor allem
voran mit dem katar der einer der
größten gaslieferanten lieferanten der
welt ist und auch von dort sollen
größere gaslieferungen nach europa
erfolgen also man will sicherstellen
dass vor allen dingen die russische
regierung das russische wirtschaft ins
system unter den sanktionen leidet und
nicht so sehr die westeuropäer
pattinson war das mit einer live
einschätzung aus washington vielen dank
dafür
eine groß angelegte
tische invasion in die ukraine das land
wird von mehreren seiten angegriffen es
gibt schwer zu verifizieren de meldungen
über ukrainische
getötete soldaten beziehungsweise
abgeschossene flugzeuge
international ist die situation relativ
eindeutig der westen verurteilt die
russischen militärschläge aufs
allerschärfste interessant ist wie
russland aktuell wie die china aktuell
reagiert das chinesische
außenministerium ruft alle seiten zur
zurückhaltung auf und sagt es handle
sich nicht um eine russische invasion
wie dies teilweise beschrieben werde wir
wollen jetzt dorthin gehen wo neue
schärfere sanktionen beschlossen wurden
beziehungsweise werden wir gehen nach
brüssel zu gunnar krüger brüssel ja auch
der sitz der nato dort wird es eine
dringlichkeitssitzung geben grunder was
wird jetzt in den nächsten stunden
passieren
da erstmal muss man vielleicht
feststellen dass dieses große
friedensprojekt die eu als dass sie sich
ja selbst versteht nun aufwacht mit dem
wahnsinn des krieges vor ihrer haustür
und das also dass ein die ganze politik
der eu der letzten wochen und monate so
mit viel diplomatie mit sanktionen die
man angedroht hat sanktionen die schon
in kraft sind dass das alles nicht
gefruchtet hat dass wladimir putin eben
doch diesen großflächigen einmal
offensichtlich in der ukraine gemacht
hat nun kann man diskutieren ob das nun
ein misserfolg der europäischen politik
war ob es vielleicht ein fehler war die
gelegenheit dazu wird es heute geben
wenn um 20 uhr die staats und
regierungschefs der eu zusammen kommen
zu einem präsenz gipfel zu einem
sondergipfel schon jetzt ist allerdings
klar zumindest verbal rückt man zusammen
ursula von der leyen wert exakt die
gleichen worte wie washington in dem sie
sagt es handele sich hier um einen nicht
gerechtfertigten nicht einen nicht
provozierten angriff also verbal rückt
der westen schon mal zusammen so lange
von der landes sagte eben vor wenigen
minuten hier in einem statement dass man
mit massiven konsequenzen auf diesen
einmal reagieren werde und sie hat auch
schon den eine dieser konsequenzen
genannte eben den dass die dass mehrere
oder dass alle russischen banken von
internationalen zahlungsverkehr
abgekoppelt werden sollten weitere
konsequenzen werde man dann heute im
laufe des tages vorstellen und die eu
staats und regierungschefs haben dann
eben auch die gelegenheit heute abend
darüber zu sprechen interessant wird vor
allen dingen sein zu schauen wie groß
die einigkeit noch ist bei der frage von
sanktionen die eben auch eigene
wirtschaftszweige treffen können wenn
also zum beispiel deutsch oder
italienische maschinenbauer von einem
exportstopp betroffen sein sollte dann
muss die einigkeit eben auch noch mal
bewiesen werden der eu außenbeauftragte
borel hat ja angekündigt wir werden die
härtesten sanktionen verhängen die es
jemals gegeben hat ist es das was
einschließt was sie gerade beschrieben
haben
ja absolut das sind eben auch die
sanktionen gegen russische banken die
abgekoppelt werden vom internationalen
zahlungssystemen die konsequenzen dafür
die haben wir eben auch schon gehört
also dass zum beispiel russische
pensionen nicht so einfach ausgezahlt
werden können dass sich russische banken
die eben auch nicht im westen
finanzieren können all das könnte das
zur konsequenz haben aber mittel und
langfristig ist wahrscheinlich so ein
exportstopp für hochtechnologie doch
viel wirkungsvoller aber da bräuchte die
eu eben einen langen atem kurzfristig
muss man vielleicht noch ankündigung
also sagen dass gerade in diesen minuten
auch der nordatlantikrat bei der nato
zusammen gekommen ist die ja hier in
brüssel auch hier ein sitz zeit der
nordatlantikrat da sind die botschafter
der nato die werden jetzt über
reaktionen der nato auf diesen ja man
muss es ja schon so nennen einen
einmarsch stellen von russland in die
ukraine beraten ganz interessant was der
nato-generalsekretär heute nacht noch in
einem statement schon gesagt hatte er
sagte wir die nato wir werden alles tun
um unsere bündnispartner zu verteidigen
und damit endete sein statement also
punkt und damit schließt sich auch ein
bisschen der kreis denn wir wissen ja
putin führt diesen krieg auch damit die
ukraine niemals mitglied der nato wird
und die nato wird das müssen wir aus
diesem statement und diesem punkt auch
einfach lesen die nato wird in der
ukraine nicht eingreifen eben weil die
ukraine kein mitglied ist aber dennoch
wahrscheinlich helle aufregung in den
baltischen staaten in polen dazu dann
wahrscheinlich im laufe des tages mehr
vielen dank für diese aktuelle
informationen live aus brüssel war dass
gunnar krüger
ukrainische innenministerium erreichen
uns jüngst noch diese meldungen
mindestens sieben soldaten seien getötet
worden 15 weitere verletzt und 19 werden
vermisst dass eine information aus dem
ukrainischen innenministerium zudem hieß
es vom grenzschutz aus der ukraine das
russische bodentruppen inzwischen
ukrainisches gebiet auch erreicht hätten
es ist jetzt kurz vor neuen wir senden
ja gemeinsam mit der ard also liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer wir werden
hier weiter bis 10 30 live berichten
also bleiben sie gerne bei uns wir
werden uns gleich mit dem ukrainischen
botschafter in deutschland hier
unterhalten über die gegenwärtige
situation lassen uns jetzt und für sie
natürlich noch mal die aktuelle lage
zusammenfassen von den kollegen von
heute express und wir begrüssen nochmal
sarah bilder hallo
guten morgen ich glaube auch noch
natürlich herzlich willkommen zur heute
express in der ukraine hat präsident
selensky den kriegszustand ausgerufene
russland hat am morgen eine
militäroffensive gestartet und
bombardiert offenbar
luftwaffenstützpunkte und andere
militärische einrichtungen in mehreren
ukrainischen städten wurden explosionen
gehört unter anderem in der hauptstadt
kiew wo es präsident biden verurteilte
den zitat ungerechtfertigten angriffe
bundeskanzler scholz sprach von einem
eklatanten bruch des völkerrechts und
sicherte dem ukrainischen präsidenten in
einem telefonat volle solidarität zu der
russische präsident putin hatte den
einsatz in der nacht im fernsehen
angekündigt un-generalsekretär ich rief
putin nach einer dringlichkeitssitzung
des un sicherheitsrates auf die truppen
abzuziehen
der krieg habe keinen sinn und verstoße
gegen die un-charta
der ukrainische präsident zielinski rief
die bürger in einer videobotschaft auf
nicht in panik zu verfallen man sei auf
alles vorbereitet und werde siegen
und im zdf morgenmagazin verurteilte
bundeswirtschaftsminister harbeck das
vorgehen russlands
es ist ein angriffskrieg russlands auf
ein souveränes land etwas was wir in
europa seit vielen jahren ich muss sagen
seit jahrzehnten nicht gesehen haben
einen angriffskrieg den mann aufs
schärfste verurteilen muss und die
deutsche solidarität gilt der ukraine
vertreter der 30 nato staaten kommen in
diesen minuten in brüssel zu einer
krisensitzung zusammen generalsekretärs
deutenberg hatte zuvor bereits den
rücksichtslosen und unprovozierten
angriffe russland scharf verurteilt das
geplante entlastungspaket der
bundesregierung als ausgleich für
gestiegene energiepreise stößt auf
kritik als sozial ungerecht bemängelten
der paritätische wohlfahrtsverband und
greenpeace das paket unter anderem soll
die ökostromumlage bereits ende juni
wegfallen die pendlerpauschale wird auf
38 cent erhöht geplant ist zudem ein
sonderzuschuss von 100 euro für hartz 4
bezieher und empfänger von
grundsicherung außerdem ein sofort
zuschlag für arme kinder von monatlich
20 euro
nach den trucker protesten in kanada
formieren sich auch in den usa lkw
konvois ein selbsternannter foxconn hat
die kalifornische stadt oakland um mit
dem ziel washington verlassen die
teilnehmer fordern dass alle corona
maßnahmen zurückgenommen werden
soweit er kurze aktuelle nachrichten
überblick und benjamin stufe macht jetzt
weiter mit dem wetter bis gleich
donnerwetter das wetter wird ihnen
präsentiert von bett1 de
vielen dank zara und guten morgen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die
tiefdruckgebiete aus dem norden die
wollen es nochmal wissen der
hochdruckeinfluss bekommt eine delle und
sie sehen hier das tief zwischen island
und skandinavien das wird sich im
tagesverlauf weiter wirksam von
nordwesten bemerkbar machen dann kann es
auch durchaus im umfeld dieses bandes
das uns passiert nochmals stürmisch
werden im moment sind das vor allem hohe
wolken allerdings im osten kommen wir
aus einer klaren nacht entsprechend
niedrig sind dort die temperaturen
zwiesel im bayerischen wald meldet heute
morgen minus fünf grad zum start in den
tag 8 grad sind es am niederrhein
und während es am vormittag noch viele
lücken für die sonne gibt wird es von
westen langsam dichter gerade in der
eifel und eben im nordwesten von der
nordsee mit der ankommenden kaltfront
gibt es dort nicht nur den regen sondern
auch den auf drehende wind zum
nachmittag liegt dann dieses regenband
zwischen mosel und lübecker bucht auch
das eine oder andere gewitter kann damit
spielen am längsten sonnige momente gibt
es im osten und südosten bei
tageshöchsttemperaturen heute dort wo
die kalte luft schon angekommen ist an
den küsten von nord- und ostsee im
einstelligen bereich werte zwischen 7
und 9 grad richtung südwesten und
südosten bis 15 grad und damit sind wir
bei den aussichten für die kommenden
drei tage morgen aprilwetter vier bis
zehn grad sehr mild regen schnee graupel
dazu auch mal ein gewitter zum
wochenende wird es trockener sonniger
und auch wieder kühler
tageshöchsttemperaturen am samstag und
sonntag zwischen 1 und 11 grad soweit
zum wetter für den moment kommen sie mit
diesen aussichten trotz allem gut in den
donnerstag
donnerwetter das wetter wurde ihnen
präsentiert von bett1 de
liebe zuschauern und zuschauer kurz nach
9 an diesem donnerstag sie sehen wir
senden immer noch angesichts der
aktuellen ereignisse denn man muss es so
formulieren es gibt krieg in europa
dementsprechend groß ist weltweit das
entsetzen seit den frühen morgenstunden
gibt es militärische angriffe und
beschlüsse seitens russlands auf die
ukraine aus russland aus belarus auch
von der annektierten halbinsel krim aus
als tragödie und fassbar als dunkler tag
für europa wurde dieser morgen schon
bezeichnet und man muss es wirklich so
sagen also ich oder wir sind
einigermaßen fassungslos sind natürlich
auch überrollt worden von diesen
ereignissen und der ukrainische
botschafter nennt das ein stück weit
naiv und meint im grunde die gesamte
haltung des westens weil jetzt das
eingetroffen ist was man lange
befürchtet wir werden später noch mit
ihm darüber sprechen genauso wie mit
unseren korrespondenten in den usa in
frankreich in brüssel und natürlich auch
in russland und in der ukraine und
dorthin wollen wir jetzt gehen unser
kollege axel sturm war heute morgen noch
in kirchen musste aber seinen standort
verlassen
der ukrainische präsident der
kriegsrecht verhängt der luftraum ist
gesperrt es gab sie reden die dann zu
hören waren und er hat mit seinem team
den standort verlassen ist jetzt mit dem
auto unterwegs zu einem
ausgesuchten ort wir werden ihnen jetzt
noch mal dazu befragen axel hallo wo
sind sie wie weit sind sie mit ihrem
team und wie ist die situation dort wo
sie sind
montiert in der
ukrainischen hauptstadt kiew
die situation des hergestellt dass im
prinzip alle großen verkehrsstraßen
komplett zerstört sind wir befinden uns
wieder viel los ist an zahlen aber nur
rückkehr am start noch umstellen
menschen ihn jetzt auch wieder hinwollen
und die pannen haben
deutschlands größten bewegungen noch zu
wollen
jeder sehen kann
bestellen wir müssen ihn an dieser
stelle die leitung beziehungsweise die
schalte unterbrechen weil die
tonqualität einfach zu schlechtes wir
wollen es später noch einmal versuchen
haben gerade bilder gesehen von
russischen panzer und das melden auch
mehrere agenturen unabhängig voneinander
russische panzer in der ost ukraine
es gibt beschüsse es gibt explosionen
das in mehreren städten und nicht eben
wie vielleicht vorher vermutet nur in
den separatisten gebieten der ost
ukraine
ministerium sind im moment diese sieben
soldaten der ukraine wurden getötet 15
weitere verletzt aber dass auch eine
meldung aus dem innenministerium es
werden keine angriffe auf zivile ziele
erwartet wir wollen überall das sprechen
und zwar hat sich heute morgen der
ukrainische botschafter andrej melik
zeit für uns genommen guten tag herzlich
willkommen gunter danke wie lernen was
hören sie von ihren landsleuten aktuell
wir haben heute früh auch mit ich habe
mit meiner mutter sie ist in lief in
lemberg in der westukraine gesprochen
mit meiner schwiegermutter in kiew die
lage ist dramatisch es gab diesen
angriff jetzt nicht nur jetzt in der ost
ukraine nicht nur in kiew sondern auch
im westen in allen ecken des landes
wurde zugeschlagen mit drohnen mit
raketen es rollen panzer jetzt aus allen
ecken aus belarus auch aus dem norden im
osten es ist ein krieg es ist ein
anderes krieg das ist ein
vernichtungskrieg der erklärt wurde und
es ist auch ein krieg nicht nur gegen
die ukraine das sollten auch die
deutschen verstehen und begreifen es ist
ein krieg gegen die gesamte freie welt
auch gegen die bundesrepublik und
deswegen hoffen wir dass unsere
deutschen freunde die bundesregierung
uns jetzt nicht nur mit solidarität bei
seite zu seite stehen sondern dass wir
auch das bekommen was was die ukraine in
diesen dramatischen stunden
erwartet und es ist der schwärzeste tag
der schlimmste tag seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg video drehen sie wissen
vielleicht es gibt hier in deutschland
unterschiedliche einschätzungen darüber
ob die menschen jetzt überrascht waren
von diesem angriff oder ob man an
irgendeiner weise vorbereitet waren wie
nehmen sie das wahr
wir haben seit fast drei monaten
beobachtet wie diese truppen
zusammengezogen wurden die russischen
truppen entlang der gesamten
staatsgrenze und natürlich wussten wir
dass das diese kriege eines tages
aus berichten und diese nacht das war um
kurz nach vier uhr morgens moskau wird
seite genauso wie im jahre 1941 hitler
kiew angegriffen hat die sowjetunion und
das ist auch etwas perfides was in
putins kopf geschah die menschen sind
vorbereitet auch die armee ist gerüstet
einen angriff abzuwehren
aber dafür brauchen wir jetzt nicht nur
die politische unterstützung nicht nur
die sanktionen seitens des westens der
eu sie müssen heute noch schnellstens
ein eingeführt werden und zwar wirklich
höllische sanktionen damit die gotische
kriegsmaschine die
gestoppt werden kann damit diese panzer
nicht mehr rollen wir wollen auch an die
menschen hier in deutschland appellieren
an die bundesregierung
bitte haben sie keine angst vor putin
hat sie heute gewandte uns nicht zu
helfen und hat auch mit mit
schlägen also mit maßnahmen gedroht die
man noch nie gesehen hat bitte habt
keine angst es ist jetzt an der zeit uns
zur seite zu stellen wenn die ukraine
fällt dann
europa als nächstes opfer dabei dass das
muss man so leider sehen und deswegen
wir brauchen auch jetzt unterstützung
für die verteidigung um die menschen zu
schützen denn die ukrainische armee ist
zwar bereit aber aber wir sind natürlich
da nach wie vor in einer position wo wir
vor einem sehr mächtigen gegner stehen
herr botschafter sie wissen ja dass es
bei uns in deutschland seit längerem
eine diskussion rund um die
waffenlieferungen gibt auch ein
politiker norbert röttgen der hat heute
morgen wieder waffenlieferungen ins
spiel gebracht und sie haben gerade
gesagt sie wünschen sich dass sie das
bekommen was sie brauchen was konkret
brauchen sie
also die liste mit defensivwaffen die
wir von deutschland erwarten erlegte
seite dem dritten februar am tisch der
verteidigungsministerin und wir hoffen
dass zumindest heute wie eine ehrliche
antwort auf diese anfrage bekommen die
deutschen wissen worum es geht man weiß
womit man uns zu helfen gang und heute
ist jetzt nicht die zeit
die ausreden ins spiel zu bringen die
ukraine ist ein partner wir sind nach
war deutschlands und wir hoffen nicht
nur auf diese politische solidarität wir
hoffen darauf dass dass wir schnellstens
die verteidigungswaffen bekommen von
deutschland von von anderen partner um
die menschen um die zivilbevölkerung zu
schützen denn wir haben jetzt mit einem
flächendeckenden mit einem groß
angelegten an einmal angriffskrieges zu
tun und das muss man vor augen führen
wir rufen auch deswegen den
bundeskanzler die bundesregierung jetzt
endlich zu handeln es ist nicht der
seite nach schuldigen zu suchen man
hätte das vielleicht auch mit
präventiven maßnahmen verhindern können
aber heute muss man endlich handeln in
der eu wir brauchen ein
milliardenschweres hilfsprogramm um die
ukrainische wirtschaft nicht kollabieren
zu lassen das ist auch ein gebot der
heutigen stunde wir rufen die kirchen
auf hier in deutschland für den frieden
in der ukraine zu beten jeden tag wir
rufen die zivilbevölkerung gerufen die
öffentlichkeit endlich aufzuwachen
die
rosarote brille auf russland die man
seit jahrzehnten getragen hat ähnliche
wegzuwerfen herr wenig gelesen zudem
heute morgen dass es bereits erste
flüchtlingen flüchtlingsbewegungen aus
den separatisten gebieten ergibt
richtung russland was wissen sie darüber
was passiert mit diesen menschen und
auch generell mit der bevölkerung in der
ukraine
so die lage ist im moment eine sehr
unübersichtliche der luftraum wurde
gesperrte um eben keine kleine
katastrophen
zuzulassen das heißt
nur auf dem landweg kann man die ukraine
im moment verlassen aber wir hoffen dass
es nicht zu einem flüchtlingsstrom kommt
wir hoffen dass diese hilfe die wir seit
monaten erwarten dass sie schnellstens
konnte auch aus berlin die deutschen
freunde wissen was zu tun ist und jetzt
ist der zeitpunkt gekommen um endlich zu
handeln der ukrainische botschafter in
deutschland andré maine et war dass ich
bedanke mich ganz herzlich für ihre zeit
und das interview vielen dank
hier ein
dramatischer ukrainische botschafter war
das und es steht wirklich schlimmste zu
befürchten russland greift die ukraine
an mehrere agenturen melden tote melden
abschüsse von flugzeugen es ist von
bombenexplosionen und raketenbeschüsse
die rede und die internationalen
reaktionen sind relativ eindeutig mann
verurteilt das aufs schärfste die nato
kommt zu einer dringlichkeitssitzung
zusammen in wenigen stunden und auch die
europäische union hat sich zu scharfen
sanktionen entschieden die schärfsten
die es hier gegeben hat also man wird
russland vom internationalen
finanzsektor isolieren aber momentan
muss man mit dem umgehen was gerade
passiert und das sind keine guten
nachrichten und wir wollen noch mal
zurück ganz kurz gehen in der nacht hat
ist diese tv ansprache gegeben von
russlands präsidenten wladimir putin in
dem er diese militäraktion ankündigte
und wir wollen von anna fest in moskau
dort geht wir jetzt hin anna noch mal
hören wie russlands präsident putin
diese aktion legitimiert hat
ja heute früh um 35 moskauer zeit also
um 3 uhr 30 deutscher zeit gab es hier
eine halbstündige fernsehansprache von
präsident wladimir putin und dort
verkündete er eben diese
militäroffensive in der ukraine seine
begründung war der angebliche völkermord
der stattfinden würde an den
russischstämmigen bürgern im osten der
ukraine und angeblich ein hilfe ersucht
der pro-russischen separatisten im kampf
um den ball gegen das ukrainische
militär und putin sagte oder forderte
ganz klar von der ukraine die waffen
niederzulegen
dann würde es auch kein schlachtfeld
geben außerdem
verkündete er
außerdem genau machte er in dieser rede
keine angaben zu umfang und dauer des
der militäroffensive in der ukraine
mittlerweile wissen wir eben dass das
ganze land betroffen sind das ziele im
westen süden und osten angegriffen
werden pro russische separatisten haben
zwischenzeitlich auch vermeldet dass sie
ein befreiungsschlag der kompletten
region der welt don jetzt und lohans
also dass kompletten das vorhaben und in
luhansk wurde vermeldet dass zwei neue
städte nun eingenommen worden sind vom
prorussischen separatisten außerdem das
vermeldete das verteidigungsministerium
hätten die russischen streitkräfte die
luftabwehr der ukraine komplett
unschädlich gemacht das
verteidigungsministerium so zitat sagte
aber auch der zivilbevölkerung droht
nichts wir hatten vor einer halben
stunde kamen hier die meldungen dass
mittlerweile auch russische bodentruppen
eingetroffen sein und zwar
militärkolonnen panzer oberhalb von kiew
in der stadt terni hilfe in der
stadthalle griff der zweitgrößten stadt
der ukraine im osten des landes und eben
in der region luhansk und das passt
alles oder was heißt das passt aber
zumindest dieser ausspruch das
verteidigungsministerium der
zivilbevölkerung der ruhe nichts der
passt zu dem was putin in seiner rede
noch sagte ich zitiere gleichzeitig
beinhalten unsere pläne nicht die
besetzung ukrainischer gebiete wir
werden niemanden etwas mit gewalt
aufzwingen sagte putin und an den westen
an seine gegner gewandt sagte er die die
versuchen sich bei uns einzumischen sie
müssen wissen dass die antwort russland
sofort erfolgen und zu konsequenzen
führen wird die sie noch nie erlebt
haben danke für diese live informationen
aus moskau angereist war das für uns
also seit ungefähr sechs sieben stunden
attackiert und greift russland die
ukraine an es gibt darauf vielfältige
reaktionen die wir für sie den ganzen
morgen schon einordnen jetzt zum
beispiel gerade das ist wenig
überraschend der dax also zu
börsenbeginn ist stark eingebrochen das
wird überall auf der welt so sei bei den
internationalen börsen der us-präsident
hat die militäraktion russlands scharf
verurteilt und sagt das wird noch eine
scharfe antwort geben ähnlich haben sich
die präsidenten vieler länder geäußert
die eu-kommission auch und ganz
interessant variiert ist wie sich china
positioniert hat weil sich das russische
außenministerium schon geäußert hat und
sagte es handle sich nicht um eine
russische invasion und
darum ist es jetzt auch interessant zu
dem ort zu gehen wo sozusagen alle
länder zusammen kommen nämlich zu den
vereinten nationen un dieser orte mitri
das ist natürlich new york und wir
schalten deshalb zu unserem
korrespondenten johannes hano heute
immerhin das mächtigste un gremium der
un sicherheitsrat der dort zusammen
trifft welche möglichkeiten hat um
dieses gremium
erstmal war es heute nacht so man hatte
schon im frühen abend damit gerechnet
dass es zu einem solchen einmarsch
russlands kommen wird man hatte
informationen dass russland den luftraum
absperrt dass man die kommunikation der
ukrainischen armee stört dass man seine
tanks und sein seine panzer in
angriffsposition bringt also man ging
davon aus dass das kurz bevorsteht
daraufhin hatte die ukraine zusammen mit
den usa eine dringlichkeitssitzung
beantragt wurde dann auch stattgegeben
es gab diese dringlichkeitssitzung auch
der un-generalsekretär gutes kam er
sagte ich habe in den letzten tagen
russlands intention immer unterschätzt
habe das nicht richtig eingeschätzt aber
diesmal will ich die lage nicht falsch
einschätzen und er hat putin
aufgefordert abzusehen von einer
invasion in die ukraine zu dem zeitpunkt
war noch nicht klar was passiert die
ganze welt hat diskutiert man hat
versucht zu überzeugen man hat versucht
die russen abzuhalten einzumarschieren
keine militäroperationen durchzuführen
man hat gesagt eine solche militär
operation würde dazu führen dass nicht
nur ein angriff auf die ukraine ist
darstellt sondern das ist ein angriff
auf die gesamte welt ordnung ist dass es
ein zurück ist zu den toten alten
reichen vor dem zweiten weltkrieg und
just als diese diskussion stattfand kam
die nachricht und das muss man sich mal
vorstellen das gremium das eigentlich
dafür da es für frieden zu sorgen also
für einen ausgleich zu sorgen just in
dieser diskussion kommt die nachricht
herein die dann der russische
botschafter auch verkündet hat dass der
präsident putin den einmarsch befohlen
hat die mir die kooperation befohlen hat
und das hat absolute fassungslosigkeit
ausgelöst man hat jetzt gesagt wann will
neue sanktionen gegen
die ukraine gegen russland durchsetzen
man will aber auch eine neue resolution
heute noch auf den weg bringen die
massiv russland angreift beziehungsweise
russland
als verantwortlichen für diesen konflikt
darstellen wird das problem ist es gibt
immer das problem mit dem vetorecht
russland hat theoretisch ein vetorecht
gegen eine solche resolution aber da
gibt es vielleicht eine möglichkeit die
un-charta zeigt gm hat eine möglichkeit
dass man auch einen betonmast
ausschalten kann in einer solchen
resolution werden sie selbst an einem
solchen konflikt beteiligt ist fest
steht glaube ich dass die un heute
ziemlich geschockt war von dem vorgehen
russlands auch von der unverschämtheit
wie man das hier bezeichnet hat vor dem
verhör der gesamten institution durch
dieses vorgehen das man bereit ist einen
schritt weiter zu gehen als sonst und
gerade johannes hano wenn eine solche
resolution zur abstimmung gebracht hat
ist ja auch ganz interessant die frage
wie sich china eigentlich positioniert
bei den olympischen spielen vor wenigen
tagen noch haben wir in china
staatspräsident hier seite an seite mit
wladimir putin gilt gesehen wie also
positioniert sich die weltmacht china
jetzt aktuell in diesem konflikt
also china hat sich in den vergangenen
jahren eigentlich immer sehr stark an
die seite russlands gestellt man hat
versucht so ein bisschen neutral zu sein
zu vermitteln auch hin und wieder aber
im grunde genommen hat man russland auch
bei film unterstützt oder man hat sich
enthalten was wir jetzt hören von den
amerikanern vor den franzosen die diese
resolution vorbereiten gegen russland
man will eine resolution bringen und das
ist das beste was man erreichen kann
glaubt man dass sich jener enthält eine
gegenstimme ein veto russlands das
möglicherweise nichts zählt dann hat man
eine neutrale stimme also eine
enthaltung von china und die restlichen
13 mitglieder der sicherheitsrats
stimmen für diese resolution das ist so
dass das beste aus der beste wie also
auf kam dieser eine solche resolution
das hofft man dass man das erreichen
kann das wird nicht leicht aber hinter
verschlossenen türen laufen da gerade
die drähte heiß man ist ein sehr großes
durcheinander hier geladen und sie
werden es weiter beobachten und uns auf
dem laufenden halten wir sprechen später
nochmal johannes hano live aus new york
war das dankeschön
ja wir erwarten heute an diesem 24
februar in einem anderen europa einem
europa in dem es krieg gibt die
schlimmsten befürchtungen sind wahr
geworden russland greift sein
nachbarland von mehreren seiten aus an
panzer rollen im land es gibt berichte
über tote soldaten abgeschossene
flugzeuge über bombenexplosionen und
raketenbeschüsse und ganz interessant
dass kam gerade hier
finde ich die meldung dass der russische
gaskonzern gazprom angekündigt hat seine
gasexporte durch die ukraine nach europa
aufrecht zu erhalten habe ich mal
gespannt was europa dazu sagt und ob man
das weiter überhaupt in anspruch nehmen
will und wird das ist interessant wir
wollen jetzt rüber gehen zu
thomas walde nach paris auch paris
beziehungsweise der französische
präsident thomas haben schon reagiert
wie lauten die reaktionen und was hat
man jetzt vor
die französische regierung und der
französische präsident haben den
russischen angriff in scharfen tönen
verurteilt präsident makro forderte
heute morgen die russische seite auf
unverzüglich diese militärintervention
zu beenden der ebc verlautete dass
präsident mal kommt mit seinem
ukrainischen amtskollegen
selensky telefoniert habe um 8 uhr
hiesiger zeit und ihm die volle summe
stützung und solidarität frankreichs
zugesagt habe in der nacht hatte der
élysée schriftlich verlauten lassen dass
frankreich die ukraine finanziell und
wirtschaftlich unterstützen wolle und
auch bei der beschaffung von
verteidigungs geräten da deutete sich
eine etwas andere position als in den
vergangenen tagen darüber die
französische position immer so ähnlich
wie die deutsche dass man nicht mit
verteidigungs geräten helfen wolle davon
ist heute morgen muss man sagen erst mal
keine rede mehr seit 9 uhr hiesiger zeit
kommt der verteidigungsrat des
französischen kabinetts zusammen und
wird sicherlich auch darüber berichten
interessanterweise
reagieren französische politikerinnen
und politiker des gesamten spektrums
ganz ähnlich wie die regierung auch
politiker der extremen linken und der
rechten die in den vergangenen wochen
noch sehr viel verständnis für russland
gezeigt hatten und sehr viel kritik für
die nato
die französische regierung sagt noch
dass ihre botschaft in kiew vorerst
geöffnet bleiben solle um franzosen in
der regierung zu unterstützen
frankreich hatte in den vergangenen
tagen alle franzosen aufgefordert die
ukraine zu verlassen aber sind
offensichtlich noch sehr viele franzosen
dort die wolle man so gut es geht in
dieser situation unterstützen da an
vielen dank für diese einschätzungen
nach paris unser korrespondent thomas
walde war dass wir haben vor ungefähr
einer halben stunde gesprochen bzw das
vergleich so lange her ich bin schon
ganz durcheinander weil ich viel weil
wir schon so lange live senden dass der
ukrainische botschafter in deutschland
andré wenig war bei uns im gespräch und
das war wirklich dramatisch seine
wortwahl eröffnet verwandten gesprochen
und wirft er dem westen auch so ein
stück weit naivität vor im umgang mit
dieser situation eine naivität übrigens
die auch der vizekanzler
bundeswirtschaftsminister robert habeck
heute morgen bei uns im morgenmagazin in
einem interview eingestanden hat und wir
machen jetzt weiter mit weiteren
reaktionen aus der bundespolitik und
dazu fragen wir unseren politischen
korrespondenten thomas reichert ja
schließen wir doch gleich daran an
thomas hat man putin unterschätzt
also man hat zumindest ausschließlich
auf eine diplomatische lösung gesetzt
man hat auch ausgeschlossen was die
ukraine zum beispiel sich gewünscht
hätte präventive sanktionen einzusetzen
um putin auf die weise vielleicht
abzuschrecken von einem einmarsch von
einer invasion insofern ist das was
robert habeck heute früh bei uns im
morgenmagazin gesagt hat eine naivität
der bundesregierung das trifft glaube
ich schon ein breites gefühl in der
hauptstadt da ist der eindruck dass
diese ausgestreckte hand der diplomatie
die hoffnung durch einen ein großes
konzert von diplomatischen initiativen
bei besuchen bei putin usw dass man darf
die reise in russland von der invasion
abbekommen will dass das gescheitert ist
und dass man möglicherweise jetzt dann
doch auch hätte anders vielleicht
reagieren müssen es gibt die diskussion
die gewinnt auch in berlin sozusagen
anfahrt dass man möglicherweise doch die
ukraine unterstützt vielleicht nicht mit
waffen aber mit material eine
außenpolitische sprecher und experte der
union aber drogen hat erklärt dass er
für waffenlieferungen sei dass ich
gezeigt habe dass sich die diplomatische
offensive nicht durchgesetzt habe das
wird interessant sein zu beobachten was
man jetzt auf jeden fall sehen wird sind
härtere sanktionen im konzert mit der eu
das einfrieren von russischen
vermögenswerten die sanktionierung von
banken also deutlich schärfere
sanktionen als wir sie vor zwei tagen
gesehen haben aber klar ist ich glaube
das kann man an diesem morgen sagen dass
dieser tag ein tiefer tiefer einschnitt
auch für berlin bedeutet für die
deutsche außenpolitik
und dass der fokus allein durch
diplomatische initiativen durch
sozusagen sanktionen die ihr die ganze
zeit im ungefähren geblieben sind dass
das gegenüber potentaten wie wladimir
putin möglicherweise nicht der richtige
weg war das heißt machen wir es noch mal
ein bisschen konkreter welche sanktionen
müssen ist jetzt wirklich sein um putin
eben zum umdenken zu bewegen
die ich glaube es herrscht eine große
zweifel in berlin und mit sanktionen la
die mir putin überhaupt zum umdenken
bringen kann die geschichte von
sanktionen in den internationalen
beziehungen macht da nicht viel hoffnung
und trotzdem gibt es große
einstimmigkeit das nur sehr scharfe
sanktionen kommen müssen die putin und
vor allem der russischen wirtschaft
wirtschaft sehr schaden noch mal das ist
möglich über das einfrieren von
vermögenswerten das ist möglich dadurch
dass man russische großbanken von zugang
zum internationalen finanzmarkt
abschneidet und das ist möglich durch
sanktionen gegen rohstofflieferungen das
wird natürlich auch uns in deutschland
und in europa treffen aber es ist so
sieht es jedenfalls heute aus der
einzige weg um putin wirklich zutreffen
die russische wirtschaft zu treffen und
vielleicht doch am ende ein kleines ein
lenker oder ein einlenken erreichen zu
können die hoffnung dass es wirklich
passiert ist
durchaus eingeschränkt denn die
wahrnehmung die die deutsche
außenpolitik im moment von von putin hat
ist dass er bereit ist für seine
großmacht hegemonialen fantasien einen
hohen preis zu zahlen thomas reichert
war das mit einer politischen analyse
der deutschen reaktionen auf die
ereignisse in der ukraine vielen dank
ein rabenschwarzer tag ist das heute
dieser vierundzwanzigster februar in der
nacht hat also russlands präsident putin
eine militäroffensive angekündigt die
jetzt in diesem augenblick fortsetzt in
der ukraine
ausnahmezustand kriegszustand der
luftraum ist gesperrt viele bürgerinnen
und bürger das lesen wir in
verschiedenen
berichten zum beispiel in der hauptstadt
kiew flüchten sich darin überein
schächter also das sind dramatische
stunden die dort gerade von statten
gehen wir fassen jetzt die situation für
sie zusammen die geschehnisse des
morgens und der nacht jetzt in heute
express mit sarah bilder
guten morgen und herzlich willkommen zur
heute express ja der brotfisch präsident
putin hat ernst gemacht in der nacht
kündigte er eine militäroffensive in der
ukraine an die läuft aktuell in mehreren
ukrainischen städten hat es explosionen
gegeben präsident zielinski hat den
kriegszustand ausgerufen
aus drohungen und ankündigung hat
präsident putin nun fakten geschaffen
bilder aus charkiw in der nacht sollen
erste angriffe zeigen
ich habe die entscheidung für eine
militär operation getroffen um menschen
zu schützen die seit acht jahren einem
völkermord durch das regime in kiew
ausgesetzt waren bis zum ende streben
wir eine entmilitarisierung und
entnazifizierung der ukraine an
deutliche worte auch in richtung anderer
länder
wer auch immer versucht uns zu stoppen
oder unser land bedroht der sollte
wissen dass russlands antwort schnell
sein wird und konsequenzen hat solche
die es in der geschichte so noch nie gab
wir sind zu allem bereit
zurzeit gibt es noch wenige bilder der
gefechte diese sollen ein angriff auf
den militärflughafen in hochdorf zeigen
russland behauptet diesen zerstört zu
haben als reaktion verhängte der
ukrainische präsident seelands geht das
kriegsrecht in einer videobotschaft rief
er seine landsleute dazu auf nicht in
panik zu verfallen wir sind stark und
auf alles vorbereitet wir werden siegen
bilder aus kiew zeigen lange staus viele
menschen die versuchen die hauptstadt zu
verlassen
und im zdf morgenmagazin verurteilte
bundeswirtschaftsminister habe ich das
vorgehen russlands
es ist ein angriffskrieg russlands auf
ein souveränes land etwas was wir in
europa seit vielen jahren ich muss sagen
seit jahrzehnten nicht gesehen haben ein
angriffskrieg den mann aufs schärfste
verurteilen muss und die deutsche
solidarität gilt der ukraine
und vertreter der 30 nato staaten
beraten zur stunde in brüssel
generalsekretärs deutenberg hatte zuvor
bereits den rücksichtslosen und
provozierten angriff russlands scharf
verurteilt das geplante entlastungspaket
der bundesregierung als ausgleich für
gestiegene energiepreise stößt auf
kritik als sozial ungerecht bemängelten
der paritätische wohlfahrtsverband und
greenpeace das paket unter anderem soll
die ökostromumlage bereits ende juni
wegfallen die pendlerpauschale wird auf
38 cent erhöht geplant ist zudem ein
sonderzuschuss von 100 euro für hartz 4
bezieher und empfänger von
grundsicherung außerdem ein sofort
zuschlag für arme kinder von monatlich
20 euro
nach den trucker protesten in kanada
formieren sich auch in den usa lkw
konvois ein selbsternannter volks konvoi
hat die kalifornische stadt oakland um
mit dem ziel washington verlassen die
teilnehmer fordern dass alle corona
maßnahmen zurückgenommen werden
soweit der kurze aktuelle nachrichten
überblick und benjamin stufe macht jetzt
weiter mit dem wetter bis gleich
donnerwetter das wetter wird ihnen
präsentiert von bett1 de
vielen dank zara und guten morgen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer herzlich
willkommen zum wetter der
tiefdruckeinfluss aus dem norden den
bekommen wir heute wieder intensiver zu
spüren dieses tiefdruckgebiet wird uns
mit seiner wetterfront einmal von
nordwesten passieren da ist auch noch
mal ordentlich wind mitspielt
heute morgen waren das meistens hohe
wolken ganz im osten kommen wir aus
einer klaren nacht entsprechend niedrig
dort die temperaturen minus zwei grad
meldet im moment zwiesel im bayerischen
wald zehn grad plus sind es in der
kölner innenstadt und das
wettergeschehen am vormittag viele
lücken für die sonne wird es geben in
der eifel wird schon dichter da sind
auch schon ein paar tropfen mit dem
spiel und im vormittagsverlauf von
nordwesten die kalt frauen dann dreht
der wind auf zum nachmittag liegt dann
dieses regenband zwischen mosel und
lübecker bucht auch das eine oder andere
gewitter kann sich dort bilden die
längsten sonnige momente im osten und im
südosten bei tageshöchsttemperaturen
heute dort wo die kalte luft des nordens
schon ankommt im einstelligen bereich
sieben bis neun grad an den küsten von
nord- und ostsee bis 15 grad richtung
oberrhein und im südosten damit sind wir
bei den aussichten für die kommenden
drei tage morgen gibt es aprilwetter
regen schnee graupel dazu gewitter noch
mal sehr mild vier bis zehn grad die
tageshöchsttemperaturen aber dann übers
wochenende mit der kalten luft klarer
trockener 1 bis 11 grad die
tageshöchsttemperaturen
wetterberuhigung und so geht es dann
auch in die kommende woche soweit zum
wetter für den moment kommen sie jetzt
trotz allem gut in den donnerstag
donnerwetter das wetter wurde ihnen
präsentiert von bett1 de
[Musik]
kurz nach halb zehn an diesem
donnerstagmorgen an dem man aufwacht in
einem anderen europa wie es heißt es
gibt krieg in europa putin hat
tatsächlich begonnen in der nacht die
ukraine anzugreifen weltweites entsetzen
und sanktionen die bereits angekündigt
wurden von diversen seiten eine
dringlichkeitssitzung ein treffen jagt
das andere nicht nur innerhalb der im
krisenstab der bundesregierung natürlich
auch auf eu ebene und auch auf nato
ebene also das ganze beschäftigt hier
jede staatsregierung die bundesregierung
die ruft im übrigen deutsche in der
ukraine inzwischen auf dringend das land
zu verlassen um 11 uhr 30 wird
bundeskanzler scholz eine
pressekonferenz gegeben und in wenigen
augenblicken und zwar um 9 uhr 45
erwarten wir ein statement von
außenministerin annalena baerbock
das wäre selbstverständlich auch live
hier begleiten werden wir haben heute
morgen schon mit dem vizekanzler arbeit
gesprochen der zur aktuellen situation
gesagt hat das sei wirklich sehr sehr
bestürzend und dass er der
westlichen politik schon ein stück weit
naivität bescheinigt hat und ähnlich
sieht es auch der ukrainische
botschafter wenig der heute ebenfalls
bei uns im interview war wir haben vor
kurzem die
bundesverteidigungsministerium von der
spd christine lambrecht vor das mikrofon
bekommen und wollen hören was sie
aktuell sagt was wir gerade erleben ist
ein brutaler angriffskrieg putins auf
die ukraine eine groß angelegte invasion
putin tritt völkerrecht mit füßen und
nimmt unfassbares leid in auch in kauf
um seine großmacht fantasien zu
befriedigen das muss ein ende haben wir
müssen geschlossen stehen in der nato in
der eu und jetzt muss es ganz schnell
wirksame konsequente sanktionen geben es
muss klar sein herr putin die nato die
eu stehen geschlossen zusammen wir
stehen zu unseren verbündeten ziehen sie
ihre truppen zurück so fort soweit also
die spd bundesverteidigungsminister in
lambrecht es ist natürlich die große
frage ob sich putin von sanktionen
aufhalten lässt es gibt auch einschätzen
aus höchsten politischen kreisen die
mutmaßen wenn putin mit dieser härte
weiter vorgeht in der ukraine dann könne
dieses land in 24 möglicherweise 48 und
eine russische provinz seien also es
besteht wirklich anlass zu größter sorge
die separatisten haben ja bereits die
einnahme von kleinstädten einer ost
ukraine gemeldet und das russische
militär hat auch verkündet die
ukrainische luftverteidigung
ausgeschaltet zu haben ohne dass es
überhaupt gegenwehr vom ukrainischen
soldaten gegeben hätte wir wollen direkt
nachfragen bei annafest in moskau von
dort aus ist sie uns zugeschaltet welche
aktuelle informationen haben sie
genau die aktuellen informationen
sind das am frühen morgen hatten ja die
separatisten die prorussischen
verkündete dass sie einen
befreiungsschlag der gesamten region don
was also der kompletten gebiete um don
jacke und blue hans bevor haben sie
hatten dann oder vermelden jetzt
stündlich und minütlich die einnahme
neuer städte in der region und soeben
sprach auch dennis puccini der chef der
selbst ernannten der volksrepublik
donetsk und er sagte dass es sehr
schnell gehen würde und dass man eben
sehr sehr schnell nun die weitere region
einnehmen werde vor wenigen tagen noch
wurden ja sanktionen verhängt die putin
offenbar wenig beeindruckt haben stellt
sich also die frage ob man da falsch im
vorwege reagiert hat und ob diese
sanktionen zu schwach waren ist das
ganze jetzt auch so eine art
trotzreaktion auf die sanktion dieser
schritt
jain wie wir das eine trotzreaktion ist
das kann ich von hier aus nicht
einschätzen aber was man in den letzten
tagen beobachten konnte ist wie schritt
für schritt alle vorkehrungen getroffen
wurde und das hat sich so ein bisschen
schritt für schritt angebahnt also
einerseits natürlich die anerkennung der
separatisten gebiete dann gab es ja eine
diskussion die hier stattgefunden hat
welche grenzen man nun an erkennt also
ob die alten grenzen von 2014 die eben
auch regionen umfassen die unter
ukrainischer kontrolle sind oder eben
die grenzen wie sie jetzt bestehen da
hat putin dann abends verkündet
naja man würde die alten grenzen wollen
also ein gebiet das mehr als doppelt so
groß ist wie das was gerade vom
prorussischen separatisten besetzt ist
und dann wurde ja schritt für schritt
diese militäroffensive
durchgewunken und hier sozusagen
demokratisch legitimiert was putin ja
eigentlich nicht gebrauchen würde er
könnte es ja auch einfach so machen aber
man ist hier jetzt gefühlt schritt für
schritt so ein bisschen auf die
fernsehansprache heute früh zu gelaufen
wo er ja dann erstmals verkündet hat
jetzt beginnt eine militäroffensive in
der ukraine
mit der begründung eben dort vor ort den
angeblichen völkermord der stattfinden
würde an russischstämmigen bürgern
abzuwenden und mit der begründung dass
man eben die prorussischen separatisten
unterstützen müsste in ihrem kampf gegen
das ukrainische militär im kompass wie
reagieren denn eigentlich die menschen
in russland auf putin zuvor gehen gibt
es da auch offene ablehnung
bisher haben wir hier an diesem morgen
und noch nicht viele offene ablehnung
erleben können in den letzten tagen
haben wir immer wieder straßen umfragen
durchgeführt und da war es schon so dass
viele menschen der logik putins gefolgt
sind die logik putins ist eben die
ukraine sei ein oder gehöre zum
staatsgebiet russland und die ukraine
müsse nun zurückgeholt werden nun ist es
ja auch so dass man in frage stellen
kann wie offen sich die menschen mit
ihrer wahren meinung vor einer kamera
äußern das ist hier höchst fraglich
anders war das mit aktuellen
informationen aus moskau dankeschön
dafür
den ganzen morgen seite 35 berichten wir
live über dieses unfassbare für viele
eigentlich ja schon ja prognostizierte
verbrechen dass das muss man so nennen
dass russlands präsident wladimir putin
begehrte angriff auf die ukraine wir
wollen darüber sprechen jetzt mit gesine
dornblüth sie ist journalistin russland
kennerin hat viele gute kontakte nach
russland erst noch einmal einen schönen
guten morgen frau domblick hallo nochmal
ihre reaktion auf das was passiert in
den vergangenen stunden ich bin immer
noch ziemlich fassungslos und mir fehlen
noch die worte das zu sagen es ist
eingetreten was
viele von uns befürchtet haben seit
langem was der eigene menschenverstand
aber nicht fassen kann und
was man befürchtet hat aber nicht ein
nicht einkalkulieren in der lage war es
ist ja jetzt so dass diese
militäroffensive umfassend gestartet
worden ist von wladimir putin das heißt
von allen möglichen seiten wird
angegriffen es ist nicht nur aus der
luft sondern man hört auch dass
bodentruppen aktiv sind und es gibt
befürchtungen dass das land also die
ukraine binnen kürzester zeit eine
russische provinz sein könnte was
glauben sie weil sie sich ja schon lange
mit russland mit wladimir putin
beschäftigen was ist sein ziel
das sind mehrere ziele also zunächst mal
geht es tatsächlich denke ich nach wie
vor putin darum zu verhindern dass ein
land in der im postsowjetischen raum
dass russland ein wenig ähnelt
erfolgreich demokratisch sein kann und
das aus reinem machtkalkül kalkül war
dass putins macht gefährden würde das
hört sich jetzt aus heutiger perspektive
ein bisschen komisch an weil es in
russland überhaupt keine opposition mehr
gibt da ist alles weggefegt worden
aber ich habe mitbekommen selber wie
2014 während des meiden damals war ich
korrespondentin in moskau für den
deutschlandfunk ich habe mitbekommen wie
damals propaganda begann gegen die
demokratiebewegung in der ukraine und
das hat sich in den letzten jahren immer
wieder verstärkt und putin kann denke
ich glaubt auch inzwischen selber dass
das von außen aus den usa gesteuerte
bewegungen seien die auf gewaltsame
umbrüche um sein und letztendlich
daraufhin auch ausgerichtet seien ihn
selbst zu stürzen das ist also dieser
eine aspekt demokratie zu verhindern der
andere aspekt kommt jetzt aber dazu in
den vergangenen jahren und insbesondere
in den vergangenen monaten es wirklich
mit den usa mit dem westen mit der
ganzen welt aufzunehmen
es gab zu beginn der olympischen spiele
in peking da hat war ja putin dort und
russland und china haben gemeinsam eine
wenig beachtete aber sehr beunruhigende
rede oder erklärung veröffentlicht darin
ist die rede davon dass russland und
china gemeinsam internationales recht
waren wollten sie berufen sich auf
eigene demokratische traditionen die
demokratie die sei eben nicht welt
umfassen sondern jedes land habe seine
eigene form der demokratie und die
minderheit damit waren die westlichen
staaten gemeint sie müssten das
akzeptieren da passiert einfach eine
aneignung und verkehrung bestehende
begriffe wie demokratie und
internationales recht und es ist
wirklich zu befürchten dass putin
wirklich selber dran glaubt und insofern
muss man vermutlich auch seine warnungen
die er in seiner rede auch an den westen
ausgesprochen hat dass nämlich jeder der
die ukraine jetzt unterstützt die
konsequenzen nie gesehene folgen
einkalkulieren müsse insofern muss man
das leider auch sehr ernst nehmen aus
westlicher perspektive erhalten viele
wladimir putin inzwischen für verrückt
weil er sich sozusagen auf diesen
konflikt einlässt russland gegen den
rest der welt sie haben china gerade
angesprochen tut er das weil er weiß
dass china möglicherweise an seiner
seite stehen wird man kann die signale
aus peking nicht so richtig deuten erst
dieses china stehe an der seite putins
dann wurde bisschen zurück gerudert bei
den vereinten nationen alle seiten
sollen zurückhaltend agieren es kann
doch gar nicht auch im sinne und im
interesse chinas sein dass dieser
konflikt so dermaßen eskaliert wie es
jetzt gerade tut ja ich glaube da muss
man wirklich die entwicklung der
nächsten tage abwarten von china als
jedenfalls nicht zu erwarten dass sich
china klar gegen russland positionierte
werden sich ein halt allenfalls denke
ich raushalten oder zurückhaltend
erstmal
die insgesamte situation putin verrückt
ja oder nein also er
kalkuliert schon sehr treffen er hat
einfach nach wie vor trümpfe und sein
haupt trumpf ist dass putin bereit ist
gewalt einzusetzen etwas was für
zivilisierte staaten ein ein tabu ist
und das gibt ihm einen vorteil der ihm
alles mögliche erlaubt weil er einfach
sich im recht des stärkeren
glaubt und er das leider auch in
gewissem maße ist wenn wir auf das
momentum schauen warum gerade jetzt das
passiert ist es möglicherweise so dass
putin den westen als so schwach verortet
also den us-präsident beispielsweise die
eu beispielsweise
das ist sicherlich ein ganz wichtiger
faktor dass er eben auf einen ein
fenster der möglichkeiten gewartet hat
und was sie gesagt haben eben das ist
eben jetzt einfach der fall amerika ist
mit sich selbst beschäftigt die eu es
mit sich selbst beschäftigt in
deutschland haben wir eine noch relativ
junge bundesregierung dazu kommt noch
ein anderer faktor der vielleicht in
bezug auf die ukraine eine rolle spielt
denn die ukraine war dabei sich zu
festigen
demokratische strukturen auszubilden die
das land hat viele probleme natürlich
der präsident mit dem sind viele auch
nicht einverstanden aber es ist ihr
präsident und es hat sich begonnen in
der ukraine wirklich eine ukrainische
identität herauszubilden die es vorher
so nicht gegeben hat und das hat man
möglicherweise in russland im kreml auch
so gesehen putin hat das gesehen und hat
vielleicht gedacht lieber früher als
später vielleicht noch eine frage weil
man ihn verstehen will aber
wahrscheinlich nicht verstehen wird den
russischen präsidenten es gab bilder
gestern vorgestern in seinem nationalen
sicherheitsrat wir engste vertraute der
mutmaßliche vertraute bloßstellte vor
laufender kamera seinen sicherheitschef
und das ließ ja schon vielleicht weit
blicken und das führt mich zu der frage
wie eigentlich der rest des landes in
russland zu diesem präsidenten steht und
nicht erkennt dass dieser mann
vielleicht jetzt jeden einzelnen in eine
situation führt die ja nicht
wünschenswert ist weil es gibt ja
mittlerweile sehr viel mehr wohlstand in
russland also es gibt da eine mitte
menschen denen es viel viel besser geht
als als vorher und das alles ist ja
jetzt in gefahr ich muss sie ist ich
muss sie leider jetzt unterbrechen
frauen blut weil wir jetzt eine aktuelle
stimme von der außenministerin haben
liebe mitbürgerinnen und liebe mitbürger
wir sind heute in einer anderen welt
aufgewacht nach monaten der vorbereitung
von lügen und propaganda hat präsident
putin heute nacht entschieden seinen
drogen schreckliche taten folgen zu
lassen mit dem militärischen angriff auf
die ukraine bricht die russische
regierung vor den augen der welt mit den
elementarsten regeln der internationalen
ordnung
russland allein hat diesen weg gewählt
wir haben in den vergangenen monaten
nichts unversucht gelassen um auch
diplomatischen wege eine friedliche
lösung für diese russland krise zu
finden
russland ist auf unsere
gesprächsangebote nicht eingegangen die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer haben nichts
getan was dieses blutvergießen
rechtfertigt dieser krieg soll vor allem
eins zerstören die hoffnung der menschen
in der ukraine
dass sie nach jahrzehnten der unfreiheit
ein recht auf demokratie ein recht auf
frieden und auf eine bessere zukunft
ohne unterdrückung haben
präsident putin diesen traum werden sie
niemals zerstören können er wächst in
der ukraine erwächst genauso in ihrem
land ich bin überzeugt auch in russland
werden viele menschen sich dafür schämen
und darüber empören dass in dem namen
russlands auf jahrzehnte mit kuppel
losen mord an ihren brüdern und
schwestern in der ukraine beschädigt
wurde
liebe mitbürgerinnen liebe mitbürger wir
alle sind heute morgen fassungslos aber
wir sind nicht hilflos wir haben uns auf
diese ereignisse vorbereitet und werden
nun gemeinsam mit unseren partnern und
alliierten vorgehen und uns dabei jeden
meter mit unseren freundinnen und
freunden in der ukraine abstimmen wir
werden uns heute im rahmen der eu im
rahmen der nato im rahmen der g7
koordinieren wir werden das volle paket
mit massivsten sanktionen gegen russland
auf den weg bringen und wir werden
unsere sicherheit und unsere
bündnispartner stärken aber heute geht
es nicht nur um europa kein land der
welt kann akzeptieren dass die
souveränität anderer zur disposition
steht wenn sein stärkerer nachbar es
will mit unseren diplomatischen netzen
in der ganzen welt wenden wir uns jetzt
an alle staaten die wie wir an die
charta der vereinten nationen glauben
sich gemeinsam dieser aggression
entgegen zu stellen
liebe deutsche staatsangehörige in der
ukraine
verlassen sie unverzüglich die ukraine
im interesse ihrer eigenen sicherheit
dazu haben wir sie in den letzten tagen
bereits mehrfach aufgefordert falls sie
das land nicht auf einem sicheren weg
verlassen können bleiben sie vorläufig
an einem geschützten ort
wir haben eine krisenhotline für
deutsche staatsangehörige in der ukraine
geschaltet sie sie können sie unter 0 30
5000 3000 jederzeit erreichen
organisierte transporte sind derzeit
nicht möglich unsere auslandsvertretung
in polen der slowakei ungarn und moldau
stehen bereit um ab der grenze
unterstützung zu leisten
mit unseren europäischen nachbarn haben
wir uns darauf gemeinsam lange
vorbereitet
tragen sie sich bitte in die online
krisenvorsorge liste des auswärtigen
amtes ein sollten sie bereits die
ukraine verlassen haben tragen sie sich
bitte aus dieser liste wieder aus
verfolgen sie die internationalen und
lokalen medien und achten sie auch auf
lokale bekanntmachung ich habe schon
gestern abend entschieden dass das noch
verbliebene entsandte personal der
deutschen botschaft in kiew aus
sicherheitsgründen abgezogen wurde wir
werden lageabhängig entscheiden ob die
botschaft ihrer arbeit vorübergehend von
lemberg oder von anderswo aufnehmen kann
liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
dieser krieg in unserer direkten
nachbarschaft wird auch für uns in
deutschland folgen haben die sanktionen
gegen russland steigende preise und
fallende aktienmärkte werden auch
rückwirkungen auf deutschland haben wir
haben uns diese situation nicht
ausgesucht wir können aber wir wollen
auch nicht ihr aus dem weg gehen die
europäische friedensordnung der letzten
jahrzehnte ist die grundlage für das
leben in wohlstand und in frieden wenn
wir jetzt nicht entschlossen dafür
eintreten werden wir einen noch höheren
preis bezahlen
herzlichen dank
wir haben die aussenministerin muss
weiter in sicherheitskabinett deswegen
haben wir leider keine zeit für fragen
also ein dramatisches statement der
bundesaußenminister in bernburg die
gesagt hat mit der adresse an wladimir
putin damit werden sie nicht durchkommen
man sei fassungslos aber nicht hilflos
es werden massive sanktionen folgen und
sie sucht den schulterschluss mit dem
westen und hat auch die
bundesbürgerinnen und -bürger auf
massive folgen eingestellt und an dieser
stelle fragen wir nochmal nach werten
gerade ein gespräch begonnen mit der
journalistin gesine dornblüth frau
dornblüth wie haben sie diese erste
äußerung der deutschen außenministerin
wahrgenommen
sehr realistisch sehr
nüchtern ich fand sie hatte einen
ernsten und beruhigenden ton die
bundesregierung wirkt tatsächlich im
bündnis mit den übrigen eu-staaten und
den usa
vorbereitet
ihre einschätzung dessen da warten wir
ja vorher darüber geredet bezüglich der
bevölkerung in russland sie vermutete da
wäre auch viel ohnmacht zu hören das ist
was was ich bestätigen kann ich höre und
lese dass tatsächlich auch von bekannten
von intellektuellen die sprechen vor
allen dingen von scham von ohnmacht der
dichter der flug in stehen der sich oft
engagiert hat für freiheit in russland
der sprach von einem taubstummen blinden
land und das sei möglicherweise noch
schrecklicher als der krieg selbst
gesine dornblüth journalistin und
russland kennerin wir bedanken uns bei
ihnen für diese einordnung gern ja wir
sind auch einigermaßen schockiert senden
seit 5 uhr 30 nicht nur einigermaßen
schockiert sondern sehr schockiert über
das was gerade passiert russland greift
die ukraine an von mehreren seiten es
ist von bombenexplosionen zu hören von
raketenbeschuss und zwar in mehreren
städten nicht nur den separatisten
gebieten es ist wirklich die schlimmsten
befürchtungen werden offenbar war und es
gibt wohl viele fluchtbewegungen aus der
ukraine ins ausland möglicherweise aber
zumindest raus aus den großen städten in
kiew er heute morgen unser kollege axel
sturm mit seinem fernsehteam aber sie
mussten abbrechen es war bombenalarm
sirenen waren zu hören und sie sind
jetzt im auto unterwegs und wir wollen
jetzt eine telefon schalte zu axel sturm
aufbauen ich glaube sie steht
möglicherweise werden wir nicht so gut
hören achse wie geht es ihnen wo sind
sie was können sie uns berichten
ja wir bauen noch mal gedroht
alle sind gesund wir mitten im auto in
kinos mit dem kompletten optionen
eröffnen sollte auch die liegen im
südwesten des landes eben schauen
richtig geschildert wir haben durch die
nacht schauen die explosion gehört
fazit jetzt schwere explosion an der
heute morgen hier noch einmal mit kamera
jetzt gesteht zu dass morgen mal das
gesamte anlage nach dem bombenalarm
ausgelöst
morgen
entschieden
wir waren durch momentan auf einer
fläche bedeckt auch die verhandlungen
die das dann später aber sichergehen
dass wieder ein sehr sehr lange staus
die menschen bewegen sich hat sich nicht
einfach auf den großen zentren und
machen sich auch im winter
es steht schlimmste zu befürchten die
außenministerin hat gerade ein
dramatisches statement an die
bundesbürgerinnen und bundesbürger
gerichtet mit einer einschätzung der
situation
haben sie sie sind seit vielen tagen
jetzt in kiew und berichten live für uns
hat sich das auch bei den bürgerinnen
und bürgern angedeutet oder ist man mehr
oder weniger kalt erwischt worden
ich glaube dass die alten menschen in
der ukraine kalt erwischt worden das gab
es vor zwei tagen
war sie unter den menschen wir haben
über 60 prozent na ja schon angespannte
situation aber es ist wirklich eine groß
angelegte träge kommt das allein zeigt
die seite gestellt da sie
die waffen einsammeln das wahr
unterstellt dass sich viele menschen und
ich glaube die ereignisse der vergangen
gemacht gibt es an der ein großer schock
wir sehen aktuell bilder von langen
autoschlangen mutmaßlich aus der
hauptstadt kiew die nur noch raus wollen
aus dieser stadt wie lautet jetzt ihr
plan was haben sie jetzt vor
ja wir sind wie gesagt wer auf der suche
nach einem sicheren produktionsstandort
wo wir wieder aufwachen können wir auch
mit unserer kamera einfangen kann was
hier vor sich geht
14 absetzen und so kontakt zu
akzeptieren dass klarheit über die
informationslage die vorgänge an der
front von lehrern an staatlichen
sehr lange nicht wirklich eine sehr
dynamische situation momentan schwer
einschätzbar ist
wirklich arbeiten vielleicht noch eine
letzte frage achse der ukrainische
präsident hat der den kriegszustand
ausgerufen hat seine landsleute
aufgefordert ruhe zu bewahren nicht in
panik zu verfallen gleichzeitig die
losung ausgegeben wir werden siegen und
alle reservisten einberufen auf der
anderen seite hat der russische
präsident ja das ukrainische militär zur
aufgabe
sozusagen aufgefordert damit es kein
blutvergießen gibt was glauben sie wie
wird die ukraine reagieren
also meinen eindruck auch in den
vergangenen wochen und monaten der
diplomatie der spitze war dass man
richtig trauern haben dass man ganz
vorne um kommuniziert wird ist das selbe
2 maxi widerspricht dem was man in der
realität beobachten kann immer wieder
hatte der kreml davon gesprochen dass
eine invasion nicht getan sei und wo der
leser sie nach inzwischen 43 weg sagt
das immer wieder hat man gesagt man
wolle nur man habe die massive
truppenkontingent ausbezahlen um mich
jetzt kommen auch die verwendeten durch
das erleben wir heute sagt einen neuen
krieg gemeint jahrhunderts in europa
also
stand der dinge passen sie auf sich und
das team auf dankeschön für diese
schilderung aus der ukraine war dass
axel sturm der sich aus der hauptstadt
kiew mit seinem team versuchte in
sicherheit zu bringen und dazu passt
petri auch noch diese meldung die uns
erreicht hat die ukrainische regierung
ruft also alle einsatzfähigen landsleute
zu den waffen wer bereit und in der lage
sei eine waffe zu halten könne sich den
streitkräften anschließend das erklärte
vor wenigen augenblicken der
verteidigungsminister wir sortieren uns
hier einen augenblick wir gehen gleich
weiter in die analyse sprechen mit
unseren korrespondentinnen und
korrespondenten und übergeben an dieser
stelle erst einmal zum
nachrichtenüberblick so heute express
und sarah bilder hallo noch mal
hallo wir fast noch mal die aktuellen
ereignisse zusammen herzlich willkommen
zur heute express der russische
präsident putin hat ernst gemacht in der
nacht kündigte er eine militäroffensive
in der ukraine an die läuft aktuell in
mehreren ukrainischen städten hat es
explosionen gegeben präsident zielinski
hat den kriegszustand ausgerufen
aus drohungen und ankündigungen hat
präsident putin nun fakten geschaffen
bilder aus aktiv in der nacht sollen
erste angriffe zeigen
ich habe die entscheidung für eine
militär operation getroffen um menschen
zu schützen die seit acht jahren einem
völkermord durch das regime in kiew
ausgesetzt waren bis zum ende streben
wir eine entmilitarisierung und
entnazifizierung der ukraine an
deutliche worte auch in richtung anderer
länder
wer auch immer versucht uns zu stoppen
oder unser land bedroht der sollte
wissen dass russlands antwort schnell
sein wird und konsequenzen hat solche
die es in der geschichte so noch nie gab
wir sind zu allem bereit
zurzeit gibt es noch wenige bilder der
gefechte diese sollen ein angriff auf
den militärflughafen in hochdorf zeigen
russland behauptet diesen zerstört zu
haben als reaktion verhängte der
ukrainische präsident selensky das
kriegsrecht in einer videobotschaft rief
er seine landsleute dazu auf nicht in
panik zu verfallen wir sind stark und
auf alles vorbereitet wir werden siegen
bilder aus kiew zeigen lange staus viele
menschen die versuchen die hauptstadt zu
verlassen
und im zdf morgenmagazin verurteilte
bundeswirtschaftsminister habe das
vorgehen russlands
es ist ein angriffskrieg russlands auf
ein souveränes land etwas was wir in
europa seit vielen jahren ich muss sagen
seit jahrzehnten nicht gesehen haben ein
angriffskrieg den mann aufs schärfste
verurteilen muss und die deutsche
solidarität gilt der ukraine
und vertreter der 30 nato staaten
beraten zur stunde in brüssel
generalsekretärs deutenberg hatte zuvor
bereitet den rücksichtslosen und
unprovozierten angriffe ausland scharf
verurteilt das geplante entlastungspaket
der bundesregierung als ausgleich für
gestiegene energiepreise stößt auf
kritik als sozial ungerecht bemängelten
der paritätische wohlfahrtsverband und
greenpeace das paket unter anderem soll
die ökostromumlage bereits ende juni
wegfallen die pendlerpauschale wird auf
geplant ist zudem ein sonderzuschuss von
100 euro für hartz 4 bezieher und
empfänger von grundsicherung außerdem
ein sofort zuschlag für arme kinder von
monatlich 20 euro
bei einer demonstration in pforzheim ist
es am abend zu auseinandersetzungen
zwischen teilnehmern und der polizei
gekommen diese setzte pfefferspray und
schlagstöcke ein anlässlich des 77 der
jahrestag der bombardierung von
pforzheim hatte es in der stadt
versammlungen rechter und linker
gruppierungen gegeben
ja soweit der kurze aktuelle nachrichten
überblick und benjamin stufe macht jetzt
weiter mit dem wetter
donnerwetter das wetter wird ihnen
präsentiert von bett1 de
vielen dank zara und guten morgen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer herzlich
willkommen zum wetter der
tiefdruckeinfluss aus dem norden der
wird sich in den nächsten stunden noch
mal mehr durchsetzen diese kaltfront
wird uns vom nordwesten erreichen feuer
kommt noch einmal sehr viel milde luft
zu uns ins land und in den vergangenen
stunden waren es vor allem die hohen
wolken die davon westen eingedrungen
sind im osten klarere verhältnisse heute
nacht deshalb entsprechend niedrig die
temperaturen zum start in den tag
zwiesel im bayerischen wald meldet im
moment -2 grad zehn grad sind es in der
kölner innenstadt und das
wettergeschehen am vormittag noch viele
lücken für die sonne allerdings richtung
eifel schon dichtere wolken und auch im
umfeld der nordseeküste im zusammenspiel
mit regen und auf drehendem wind das
kann durchaus stürmisch werden wird dann
spätestens zum nachmittag dann liegt
dieses regen bahn zwischen der moose und
der lübecker bucht auch das eine oder
andere gewitter wird mit reinspielen am
längsten sonnige momente gibt es
richtung osten und südosten bei
tageshöchsttemperaturen dort wo die
kalte luft schon angekommen ist im
einstelligen bereich an den küsten von
nord- und ostsee werte zwischen 7 und 9
grad im süden im südwesten und im
südosten bis 15 grad jetzt der blick auf
die aussichten für die kommenden drei
tage morgen aprilwetter regen schnee
graupel und gewitter noch mal sehr mit
vier bis zehn grad in den folgenden
tagen dann deutlich kühler aber auch
trockener tageshöchsttemperaturen
zwischen 1 und 11 grad ruhig geht es
dann auch in die kommende woche soweit
zum wetter für den moment kommen sie
jetzt trotz allem gut in diesen
donnerstag
donnerwetter das wetter wurde ihnen
präsentiert von bett1 de
kurz nach 10 an diesem donnerstag liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer sie sehen
wir sind weiter auf sendung hier im
morgenmagazin ganz anders als sonst aber
das natürlich der aktuellen weltlage
geschuldet inzwischen werden sie es
mitbekommen haben es gibt krieg in
europa putin hat in den frühen
morgenstunden bei uns in der nacht
begonnen die ukraine anzugreifen und
zwar aus drei seiten aus der luft laut
ukrainischen grenzschutz gibt es
inzwischen auch bodentruppen die die
ukraine erreicht haben möglicherweise
auch von wasserseite aus und so viel
lässt sich im moment schon festhalten
auch wenn viele informationen noch nicht
verifiziert werden konnten dieser
angriff beschränkt sich offenbar nicht
nur was man am anfang noch gedacht hatte
auch den osten des landes sondern putin
hat da offenbar noch mehr vor russische
panzer rollen in der ukraine die
nachrichtenagentur ap meldet das
russische militär fahrzeuge jetzt auch
von der ukrainischen halbinsel krim aus
in die ukraine einfahren es ist der
schwärzeste tag in europa seit
jahrzehnten so schätzen dass viele
politikerinnen und politiker ein
annalena baerbock die bundes
außenministerin hat vor gut 15 minuten
ein dramatischer statement an die
bundesbürgerinnen und bundesbürger
gerichtet man sei fassung aber nicht
hilflos und sie setzt jetzt auf ein auf
das massivste zitat sanktionspaket und
forderte alle bundesbürger rinnen und
bundesbürger auf das land natürlich zu
verlassen man solle sich auch
schwerwiegende folgen auch einstellen
die diese militär eskalation nach sich
ziehen wir den ganzen morgen reden harry
hat und ich mit expertinnen experten und
unseren komponenten in allen möglichen
städten wir gehen jetzt noch mal zu
meiner kollegin anna feist nach moskau
anna wies die situation aktuell
ja es wird hier minütlich gibt es neue
meldungen darüber welche neuen städte
und ziele in der ukraine eingenommen
worden sein sollen bzw angegriffen
worden sein sollen und am frühen morgen
war es oder vor wenigen stunden war es
so dass eben auch die prorussischen
separatisten aufgerufen haben zu einem
großen befreiungsschlag der gesamten
regionen im don passt also komplette
lohans und don jetzt und vor etwa einer
halben stunde vermeldete dennis puschel
ihn der chef der selbst ernannten
volksrepublik doña dass man sehr schnell
vorgehen würde sehr schnell die gebiete
dort eben einnehmen werde immer wieder
gibt es hier das narrativ das angeblich
nur ukrainische militärische
infrastruktur angegriffen werde also
dass sämtliche russischen attacken
darauf zielen aber auch wir haben hier
die meldungen darüber dass eben
russische bodentruppen nun auch von
verschiedenen
also einmal von belarus aus einmal von
der krim aus und einmal auch im osten
des landes wohl angreifen würden und
unterwegs sein unterdessen hat
lukaschenko wohl gesagt dass belarus
selber belarussische soldaten sich
selber wohl nicht beteiligen apropos
narrativ anna an merkwürdigen absurden
reden von putin hat es in den letzten
tagen nicht gemangelt und eine weitere
ist ja in der nacht hinzu kommen nämlich
die tv ansprache in der er diese
militäroffensive angekündigt hat und ja
auch begründete womit und wie
wir hatten hier um 5 uhr 30 an diesem
morgen lief eben eine halbstündige rede
putins die ähnlich wie die rede am
montagabend ja sehr geschichtsträchtig
war und sehr ausführlich die schritte
begründete und die kern begründung ist
ein bisschen der angebliche völkermord
der gerade stattfinden würde im osten
der ukraine an den russischstämmigen
bürgern dort und ein hilfe ersucht der
pro-russischen separatisten und dieses
hilfe besucher geht ja zurück auf eben
die anerkennung der separatisten gebiete
und auf ein dekret das montagabend
geschlossen wurde gemeinsam mit den
separatisten führern über gemeinsame
verteidigung der separatisten gebiete
der selbsternannten volksrepublik
johanns in der rede hat putin auch
gesagt die ukraine möge ihre waffen
niederlegen dann würde es auch kein
schlachtfeld geben aber die räder hat
keinen aufschluss gegeben darüber in
welcher dauer und in welchem umfang eben
diese militäroffensive auf die ukraine
stattfinden soll und ich habe zwei
zitate aus dieser rede
nämlich einmal
putin gewandt an die politischen feinde
oder bzw an den westen also die jetzt
sich dagegen stellen könnten die die
versuchen sich bei uns ein zu müssen
mission sie müssen wissen dass die
antwort russlands sofort erfolgen und zu
konsequenzen führen wird die sich noch
nie erlebt haben außerdem sagte putin
dass er das gebiet die ukraine nicht
besetzen will
genau das waren so ein bisschen die
kernaussagen aus dieser rede danke schön
danke an als live aus moskau
dieser krieg wird für uns alle folgen
haben hat die bundes außenministerin
gesagt und ja das steht natürlich zu
befürchten dass das auch eintreten wird
an der stelle ist es zeit in das land
selbst zu gucken in die ukraine und das
wollen wir tun er jetzt schauen wir nach
levi fin den westen der ukraine dort ist
unser korrespondent lothar becker denn
auch von dort wurde ja beschuss
inzwischen gemeldet wie geht es ihnen
und wie es die lage vor ort
wie ich vor wenigen minuten gehört habe
verifizieren kann ich nichts handelt es
sich bei dem beschuss in der nähe von
lemberg lviv hier wo wir sind auch um
eine luke um einen lift
luftwaffenstützpunkt der ukrainischen
luftwaffe der beschossen worden sein
soll vor einigen stunden
das deckt sich mit den meldungen dass
eben alle
luftwaffenstützpunkte in der ukraine
also außerhalb des donners auch die
stützpunkte beschossen wurden
offensichtlich mit raketen um die
ukrainische luftwaffe an der stelle hart
zu treffen was auch gelungen sein soll
und so können wir sagen hier in lemberg
merken die menschen dass nun auch wir
sehen menschen die mit großen gepackten
taschen durch die straßen gehen es ist
hier keine panik die spürbar wäre in den
straßen aber es gibt ja so gut wie
keinen berufsverkehr den wir sonst die
immer beobachtet haben und die menschen
stellen sich darauf ein möglicherweise
aufs land hinaus zu fahren weil sie sich
dort sicherer fühlen allerdings die
straßen in der ukraine sind blockiert
überall sind staus kaum ein vorankommen
zumindest längst nicht in den zeiten in
denen man vielleicht hofft ein ziel
erreichen zu können und so entwickelt
sich die situation gerade auch im westen
der ukraine dahingehend dass menschen
versuchen sich in sicherheit zu bringen
es ist schwierig oft für uns alle
meldungen die uns in diesen momenten
erreichen während sich die ereignisse
überschlagen zu verifizieren und richtig
einzuordnen deshalb würden wir gerne bei
ihnen nachfragen welche informationen
sie derzeit über tote und verletzte
haben
momentan kursieren recht geringe zahlen
über tote und verletzte
es gibt sie ob die zahlen stimmen kann
auch ich nicht sagen es gibt eine
einstellige zahl über getötete ukraine
und verwundete es gibt eine meldung
wohlgemerkt unbestätigt aus ukrainischer
seite dass es 50 getötete russen geben
soll ob es sich dabei um separatisten
handelt oder russische soldaten ist
unklar was sicher ist ist dass der
ukrainische präsident selensky andere
staaten nach dem angriff nun auch um
verteidigungs hilfe gebeten hat das
scheint sicher und fordert hilfe beim
schutz des ukrainischen luftraums das
deckt sich mit der hart getroffenen
ukrainischen luftwaffe mit meldungen
dass die stützpunkte größtenteils
zerstört sein sollen außerdem
evakuiert wohl auch der süden oder wird
der süden der ukraine
evakuiert es soll zugegeben die menschen
aus der region um odessa herausfahren
und der was ich finde ukrainische
verteidigungsminister hat zu den waffen
gerufen wörtlich sagte jeder der in der
lage seine waffen waffe zu halten könnte
die territorialen verteidigungskräfte
unterstützen und insgesamt ist die lage
nun auch angespannt weil so schätze ich
dass zumindest ein viele menschen in
ihren fahrzeugen auf den straßen der
ukraine unterwegs sind und diese straßen
aber auch wege sind die russische panzer
bei ihrem vorstoss nutzen könnten so
dass also hier nun ein
aufeinandertreffen von zivilisten mit
russischen bodentruppen nicht
auszuschließen ist und man kann nur
hoffen dass da keine fehler passiert ist
ja schon ein aufruf wo man tatsächlich
hinhört dass alle landsleute aufgerufen
sind sich den streitkräften anzurufen so
lange sie eine waffe halten können wie
reagiert denn die bevölkerung
wir haben heute morgen hier direkt nur
telefonischen kontakt gehabt oder per
messenger diensten und konnten
feststellen dass die menschen deutlich
geschockt reagiert haben als wir es in
den letzten tagen erlebt haben das ist
eine einen konflikt geben könnte im
donbass das war vielen menschen klar
dass es aber eine form von angriff auf
die ganze ukraine geben würde das haben
bis zuletzt auch in umfragen zwei
drittel der ukraine eigentlich für
unwahrscheinlich gehalten
nun gibt es diesen flächen deckenden
angriff der im moment für viel
verunsicherung sorgt und panikreaktionen
sicherlich auch weil eben man in den
städten sirenen hört oder sogar
explosionen hören kann die eben von den
angriffen auf die militärische
stützpunkte stammen nur das weiß in dem
moment ja niemand in dem er so eine
explosion hört oder gar sieht es gibt
auch videoaufnahmen so dass die reaktion
der menschen ganz natürlich ist sich
jetzt irgendwie in sicherheit zu begeben
sicherheit das ist für viele menschen
habe ich in den letzten tagen hier
gelernt das land man versucht verwandte
aufzusuchen die in kleinen dörfern leben
und hofft dass man dort weniger
gefährdet ist als in den großen städten
und das sorgt für diese große bewegung
andererseits haben sich ukraine auch
ernsthaft vorbereitet in den letzten
wochen es gab erste hilfe kurse bis
runter zu schulklassen die mit und
verbänden und dem verhalten im
krisenfall geschult wurden aber auch
menschen die für den dienst an der waffe
trainiert haben in den letzten wochen
auslief im westen der ukraine war dass
lothar becker mit aktuellen
informationen wir bedanken uns ganz
herzlich passen sie gut auf sich auf
angriff auf die ukraine von seiten
russlands und mehreren flanken aus wird
diese operation durchgeführt
die regierungen der westlichen länder
haben gerade alle eine
dringlichkeitssitzung nach der anderen
einberufen zurzeit zb takt jetzt das
sicherheitskabinett im bundeskanzleramt
das
innenministerium außenministerium
verteidigungsministerium und da erwartet
man ein statement gegen 11 uhr 30 das
was urlaubsort morgen schon gesagt hat
ist das ist ein schlechter tag für die
ukraine sei und ein schwarzer für europa
der us-präsident beiden sagt präsident
putin hat sich vorsätzlich für einen
krieg entschieden der katastrophale
todesfälle und menschliches leid bringen
wird russland alleine ist für den tod
und die zerstörung diese die dieser
angriff bringen wird verantwortlich eine
schlüsselrolle in dieser eskalation wird
china spielen und es ist interessant wie
china reagiert wir gehen jetzt nach
peking zu unserer korrespondentin
christiane hoffmann schönen guten morgen
schönen guten tag muss man sagen wie
reagiert peking sonntag
china steht an der seite von russland in
diesem konflikt und zwar hat der
chinesische vertreter bei den vereinten
nationen gesagt man solle weiter
verhandeln und man solle doch die
souveränität der staaten achten
allerdings hat gestern die chinesische
die sprecherin des chinesischen
aussenministeriums auch gesagt dass nato
die nato der aggressor sei denn sie habe
in den zurückliegenden jahren eine
vereinbarung mit russland gebrochen nach
der eben keine nato osterweiterung
stattfinden soll china hält also hier
dem russland auch den rücken frei und
steht an der seite russlands das sieht
man auch daran oder konnte man schon
erahnen
als kurz vor beginn der olympischen
spiele
präsident putin hier in peking war und
sich quasi von präsident rückendeckung
geholt hat sie haben gleichzeitig eine
strategische allianz besiegelt besiegelt
gegen die nato und gegen die usa
insofern wird man jetzt schauen müssen
wie china weiter reagiert auf jeden fall
ist sicher dass china doch die situation
ganz genau beobachten wird und schauen
wird wie geschlossen reagiert denn der
westen auf die aggression putins und das
sicherlich auch mit blick auf seinen
konflikt mit taiwan denn da hat china ja
auch ambitionen wir sind gespannt wie
das weitergeht vielen dank fürs erst der
nach peking christian hoffmann war dass
unsere korrespondentin obwohl es
natürlich verschiedene erzählungen jetzt
gerade gibt aber wenn das chinesische
außenministerium sagte es handele sich
nicht um eine russische invasion da weiß
man natürlich auch nicht was das jetzt
soll aber das gehört wahrscheinlich mit
zu diesem instrumentarium dass man sich
jetzt gerade bedient beschäftigen ende
tut ist in jedem fall jede
staatsregierung in diesen augenblicken
auf unterschiedlichen ebenen auf
landesebene natürlich aber auch auf eu
und auf nato ebene deswegen wollen wir
jetzt mal nach brüssel zu unserem
korrespondenten werner krüger zuständig
für alles rund um die nato und die eu es
gab eine dringlichkeitssitzung auf nato
ebene gunnar krüger welcher offizielle
reaktion gibt es denn da
vielleicht muss man erst mal feststellen
dass die eu die sich ja als das große
friedensprojekt für europa versteht dass
sie heute aufwacht und den wahnsinn des
krieges vor ihrer haustür feststellen
muss also all die diplomatie die man in
den letzten wochen und monaten hier
gemacht hat weil die sanktionen mit
denen man gedroht hat und auch die
sanktionen die schon seit montag
beschlossen und heute nacht in kraft
getreten sind die alle haben wladimir
putin nicht von seinem schritt abhalten
können die ukraine in die ukraine
einzumarschieren und da muss sich die eu
natürlich schon fragen ob ihre politik
tatsächlich von erfolg gekrönt war sie
muss sich vielleicht auch fragen ob
diese ganze politik ein fehler war und
die gelegenheit dazu bietet sich heute
abend um 20 uhr in einem eigentlich
einberaumten
sondergipfel der eu staats und
regierungschefs also alle 27 werden hier
in präsenz
zusammenkommen was man vielleicht jetzt
schon sagen kann ist dass diese dass
dieser angriff von russland auf die
ukraine den westen auf jeden fall geeint
hat wo solar von der leyen hat sich
heute morgen in den exakt gleichen
worten geäußert wie das auch der 1
ricanische präsident joe biden gemacht
hat wie das der nato-generalsekretär
gemacht hat sie spricht von einem nicht
gerechtfertigten nicht provozierten
angriff und sie hat schon gesagt was sie
den staats und regierungschefs heute
vorschlagen wird und zwar ein neues
massives
sanktionspaket und dazu würden dann auch
sanktionen gegen weitere russische
banken zählen die vom internationalen
zahlungsverkehr dahin abgeschlossen
abgeschnitten werden sollen trotzdem
kunden noch eine kurze nachfrage muss
sich der westen natürlich auch fragen
lassen wieso hat man das nicht kommen
sehen und hat man da im vorwege zu naiv
reagiert und gehandelt
ja diese naivität die man sich
vielleicht vorwerfen muss da muss man
natürlich die gegenfrage stellen was
wäre die alternative gewesen also seit
heute morgen tagt ja auch die nato die
verteidigungsminister der nato in einem
sondertreffen und nato-generalsekretär
stoltenberg daher hat offensichtlich
heute nacht nicht geschlafen herzlich
schon um kurz nach vier zu wort gemeldet
und auch er spricht natürlich mit
denselben aktiven von diesen konflikt
aber setzt am ende auch einen satz und
der lautet die nato wird mit
entschlossenheit alle ihre
bündnispartner verteidigen punkt und da
schließt sich eben auch der kreis in
diesem punkt denn putin führt ja diesen
krieg auch um zu vermeiden dass die
ukraine je mitglied der nato wird und
die nato das liest man aus diesem
statement sie wird auf keinen fall in
diesem konflikt
eintreten eben weil die ukraine kein
mitglied der nato ist gunnar krüger
dankeschön für diese einschätzung aus
brüssel danke sehr
ja auch in den sozialen netzwerken
können sich vorstellen ist der teufel
los da kursieren viele bilder des
russischen einmarsch in die ukraine und
wir können uns vielleicht einiges davon
jetzt einmal anschauen man sieht panzer
die von der halbinsel krim aus in die
ukraine wollen und wir können natürlich
wenig sagen
wann das war oder zur und vor allen
dingen zur echtheit dieser bilder hier
sehen wir jetzt der lange autoschlangen
das ist das was unser korrespondent
axel sturm und gerade auch bestätigt hat
die menschen versuchen natürlich abfall
aus den großen metropolen rauszukommen
aber es gibt autos lang und lange staus
über all das war gerade rauch über der
flotten basis in odessa am schwarzen
meer offensichtlich also auch über den
seeweg die militärische konfrontation
und wie gesagt noch mal all diese bilder
können wir nicht verifizieren aber das
gehört natürlich auch zu dieser
situation dazu es ist natürlich auch ein
krieg der informationen eine ganze reihe
an reaktionen gab es bereits heute
morgen auch hier bei uns im programm
eine davon wollen wir ihnen jetzt noch
einmal einspielen und zwar von der
verteidigungsministerin der spd
politikerin christine lambrecht
was wir gerade erleben ist ein brutaler
angriffskrieg putins auf die ukraine
eine groß angelegte invasion putin tritt
völkerrecht mit füßen und nimmt
unfassbares leid in auch in kauf um
seine großmacht fantasien zu befriedigen
das muss ein ende haben wir müssen
geschlossen stehen in der nato in der eu
und jetzt muss es ganz schnell wirksame
konsequente sanktionen geben es muss
klar sein herr putin die nato die eu
stehen geschlossen zusammen wir stehen
zu unseren verbündeten ziehen sie ihre
truppen zurück sofort sagt also die
bundesverteidigungsministerium christine
lambrecht der bundeskanzler scholz wird
sich auch in kürze nochmal offiziell
erklären der vizekanzler der war heute
morgen schon bei uns im zdf
morgenmagazin interviewen hat folgendes
gesagt
es ist ein angriffskrieg russlands auf
ein souveränes land etwas was wir in
europa seit vielen jahren ich muss sagen
seit jahrzehnten nicht gesehen haben
einen angriffskrieg den mann aufs
schärfste verurteilen muss und die
deutsche solidarität gilt der ukraine
wir waren heute morgen mit ihnen
verabredet zu einem gespräch wir wollten
über die energiesituation sprechen die
sich jetzt mutmaßlich stark verschärfen
wird womit rechnen sie jetzt wir müssen
damit rechnen dass sich kurzfristig an
den rohölmärkten oder sogar an den
gasmärkten die preise
nach oben bewegen aber schon
mittelfristig haben wir gute chancen
dass wir die preis den preisanstieg
durch den krieg wieder dämpfen können
die versorgungssicherheit in deutschland
zu gewährleisten ist jetzt meine oberste
aufgabe so weit der wirtschaftsminister
und auch vizekanzler robert habeck heute
morgen hier bei uns im interview und
gesprochen haben wir heute morgen auch
mit der cdu partei und
fraktionsvorsitzenden friedrich merz
ja es ist natürlich ein schock es ist
krieg in europa und ich will das hier
ausdrücklich an dieser stelle sagen wir
werden als cdu/csu und auch als
bundestagsfraktion die bundesregierung
auch die europäische union bei allen
diesen bemühungen unterstützen es wird
jetzt hier keine innenpolitische
diskussion über dieses thema geben
sondern allenfalls intensive beratungen
sowie sie übrigens diese woche auch
schon stattgefunden haben und das
allerwichtigste was jetzt erreicht
werden muss und ich bin sicher wir
werden es erreichen ist eine große
geschlossenheit der westlichen
staatengemeinschaft 'nen auch der
demokratien der welt gegen diesen
angriff auf die demokratie
der partei und fraktionschef der cdu
friedrich im märz wir wollen uns noch
mal die deutsche perspektive auf diese
eskalation einschätzen lassen und
sprechen jetzt mit unserem
hauptstadtkorrespondenten mit thomas
reichert thomas noch einmal guten morgen
das sicherheitskabinett tag was passiert
denn jetzt in der tat das
sicherheitskabinett tritt zusammen das
ist eine verbindung von ministern
außenminister in ist der bundeskanzler
auch die dienste der bundes für
verfassungsschutz der bnd sind da
vertreten das tritt nur in besonderen
situationen wie eben der jetzigen
zusammen für 11.30 ist ein statement von
bundeskanzler olaf scholz angekündigt
die g7-staaten tagen unter vorsitz
deutschland in einer video-konferenz
auch die nato partner werden tagen er
wird also heute einiges passieren und
wir werden klarer sehen wie deutschland
wie europa auf diese invasion russlands
in der ukraine reagieren wird es wird
vermutlich hier auch in diesem
sicherheitskabinett um die sicherheit
deutscher staatsbürger gehen die
aussenministerin annalena baerbock hat
vor etwa einer stunde einen dramatischen
appell auch an deutsche in der ukraine
gesendet sie sollten das land unbedingt
verlassen wenn das irgendwie möglich sei
und sie hat davon gesprochen das
massivste sanktionen nun in gang gesetzt
werden sollten gegen russland in thomas
sie sind ja nah dran an der hauptstadt
politik heute morgen haben wir robert
habeck gesprochen den vizekanzler der
auch ein stückweit naivität eingestanden
hat und diese situation betrachten wir
sehen sie es ich glaube das trifft ein
gefühl das sich weit verbreitet ist
inzwischen in berlin die bundesregierung
hat unterstützt von den meisten parteien
erst einmal natürlich auf diplomatie
gesetzt
auch die forderung aus der ukraine oder
aus manchen baltischen staaten
präventive sanktionen einzusetzen gegen
russland quasi als abschreckung vor
einer invasion der hat sich deutschland
wie andere eu staaten auch dagegen
entschieden es herrscht hier ist im
moment ein gefühl von fassungslosigkeit
und auch den eindruck dass die
ausgestreckte hand zu diplomatie von
russland von vladimir putin weg
geschlagen worden sei und dass es
sozusagen hier sich um ein kühl geplante
aggression gegen ein europäisches land
hantel das wird ein tiefer einschnitt
für die deutsche politik in soweit sein
als man sich natürlich fragen kann ob
der ansatz allein auf diplomatie zu
setzen hilfreich war s gewinnt an fahrt
eine diskussion darüber wie man ob man
die ukraine doch unterstützen kann
vielleicht nicht mit
mit mit waffen aber mit militärischem
gerät oder mit militärischem material
also da verändert sich in dieser
dramatischen lage auch in berlin einiges
gerade dann vielen dank für diese
einschätzung thomas reichert auch für
sie wird das heute noch eine
arbeitsintensiver tag werden das waren
auch für uns hier im zdf morgenmagazin
dramatische stunden absolut seit
ungefähr sechs stunden muss man sagen
läuft der angriff in der ukraine
auf die bilder können wir zum abschluss
vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz schauen
die zeigen wir ihnen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer das
entsetzen weltweit auf das was ich im
osten vor allem in der ukraine derzeit
tut ist ja wirklich massiv panzer rollen
auf ukrainischem staatsgebiet also die
invasion russlands von verschiedenen
flanken und es gibt einschätzungen von
höchster politischer ebene die
befürchten dass das jetzt schnell gehen
könnte jetzt wird hier gleich um 10.30
ein heute spezial beginnen das läuft bis
12 uhr wir bedanken uns für das
interesse wünschen ihnen ja ein halbwegs
guten tag alles gute das mal und jetzt
direkt nach mainz zum heute spezial
[Musik]
mein wunsch war immer reporterin zu sein
der 10 die geschichten von menschen um
uns der wahrheit anzunähern
das ist wie ein geschenk und wir müssen
damit kritisch und behutsam umgehen
gerne zimmermann zdf london
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu einem heute
spezial es ist krieg in der ukraine
allen diplomatischen bemühungen zum
trotz hat russlands präsident putin am
morgen eine militäroffensive gestartet
russische truppen bombardierten offenbar
luftwaffenstützpunkte und andere
militärische einrichtungen in der
ukraine
diese bilder sollen die angriffe zeigen
in mehreren ukrainischen städten waren
explosionen zu hören
material von augenzeugen zeigen
militärhubschrauber die über lohans
fliegen sollen der ukrainische präsident
selensky hat den kriegszustand
ausgerufen nach dem russischen angriff
hat er nun andere staaten zur
verteidigungs hilfe aufgerufen er
forderte hilfe um den ukrainischen
luftraum zu schützen in der hauptstadt
kiew heulten die sirenen
die deutschen diplomaten sind nun dabei
kiew zu verlassen
und jetzt schalten wir live zu meinem
kollegen lothar becker der ist in
lemberg lothar wo halten sie sich denn
da jetzt genau auf und was passiert um
sie herum
und wir sind hier im stadtzentrum von
lift zu deutsch lemberg hinter uns kann
man vielleicht noch teile der oper sehen
wir sind hier mitten in der stadt und
dieser morgen hat sich verglichen zu den
anderen tagen hier natürlich auch ganz
anders angefühlt es gibt keinen
berufsverkehr generell weniger autos in
der stadt das dürfte darauf hindeuten
dass viele menschen versuchen die stadt
eben zu verlassen das problem der gerade
geschilderten explosionen die in vielen
städten der ukraine zu hören waren ist
ja dass niemand weiß wo diese app
explosionen stattgefunden haben
zumindest nicht wenn er sie hört früh
morgens wenn das passiert so haben viele
menschen eben die stadt viele städte
sicherheitshalber verlassen wollen was
jetzt zu großen staus entlang aller
verkehrsachsen der ukraine führt dort
kommt man kaum voran tatsächlich scheint
es aber so zu sein dass der russische
erst gegen die ukraine so stattfand das
mit raketen primär militärische ziele
angegriffen also ausgeschaltet wurden
das scheint in großen teilen auch binnen
weniger stunden gelungen zu sein
gleichzeitig wurde im donbass also im
konfliktgebiet wo dieser krieg
eigentlich seit 2014 herrscht und den
alltag dominiert dort ist man mit
bodentruppen vorgerückt ukrainische
quellen sagen dass dort zum beispiel
aber auch brücken gesprengt werden um
diesen einmarsch der russischen truppen
im donbass zumindest zu verlangsamen
gleichzeitig noch diese meldungen dass
an verschiedenen stellen der
ukrainischen grenze also zu russland
aber auch zu
belarussischen russische truppenverbände
einmarschiert sind was deren ziele sind
ist noch unklar es gibt berichte von
verletzten und auch toten was können sie
uns darüber berichten was weiß man
im moment ist auch da die datenlage und
die meldungslage ambivalent es gibt
meldungen von der einen seite die kurz
danach von der anderen seite dementiert
werden es scheint eine verglichen mit
der breiten angriffs front die es ja in
dem sinne nicht ist aber mit den
verbreiteten angriffen an verschiedenen
stellen in der ganzen ukraine eine
relativ geringe zahl an toten zu
beklagen geben und verwundeten es gibt
eine zahl die mit sechs genannt wurde
aber doch das ist schon eine weile her
sodass sie man nicht weiß ob sie stimmt
und biopsie noch aktuelles ukrainische
quellen behaupten es gebe bis zu 50 tote
russische soldaten oder pro russische
soldaten im donbass auch da können wir
nicht sagen dass dies tatsächlich stimmt
was wir wissen ist dass die ukraine das
die ukrainische bevölkerung sich in den
letzten tagen und wochen auf so eine
situation vorbereitet hat auch wenn man
sie niemals erwartet hat umfragen haben
ja noch vor wenigen tagen gezeigt dass
gut zwei drittel oder knapp zwei drittel
der ukrainischen bevölkerung nicht von
so einem flächendeckenden breiten
vorgehen der russischen truppen
ausgegangen sind trotzdem gab es
vorbereitungen schulklassen konnten
erste hilfe kurse besuchen ganz normale
einwohner hier in wir konnten das auch
machen andere haben sich für den dienst
an der waffe
beworben haben trainings durchgeführt
und das ist auch heute der aktuelle
stand aus hier von seiten der regierung
hier dort gibt es einen aufruf jeder der
eine waffe halten könne solle sich
melden und könnte bei der territorialen
verteidigungs truppe hier der ukraine in
dienst gestellt werden und wie reagiert
die ukrainische regierung außerdem noch
in dieser jetzigen situation wie verhält
sie sich
präsident zielinski hat noch in der
nacht per twitter mehrsprachig
kommuniziert er hat um ruhe gebeten er
hat wie auch in den tagen zuvor darum
gebeten dass man bitte nicht in panik
verfallen sollte dass die menschen bitte
zu hause bleiben sollen das war zu einer
zeit als niemand genau wusste wie diese
russische angriff aussehen würde und man
war sich auch seitens der ukrainischen
regierung sicher dass man gut
vorbereitet ist dass die ukrainischen
streitkräfte auch in der lage wären
angriffe der russischen truppen
abzuwehren das scheint nun zumindest bei
der luftwaffe nicht der fall gewesen zu
sein ist scheint wohl so gewesen zu sein
dass die sehr schnell ausgeschaltet
werden konnte es ist wohl zu viel luft
gefechten gekommen dazu haben wir keine
angaben aber klar ist dass ein so
massives eindringen der russischen
truppen in dieser stärke auch mit dieser
präzision sicherlich der ukrainischen
regierung und damit eben auch dem
verteidigungsministerium und den
streitkräften schwer machen hier noch
etwas auszurichten in dem sinne dass man
die kontrolle über die situation
zurückgewinnen könnte vielen dank lothar
becker und wir gehen direkt von der
ukraine nach russland und schalten live
zu meinem kollegen christian senn nach
moskau christian wie hat wladimir putin
diese militäroffensive denn genau
begründet
wladimir putin hat das wahr gemacht von
dem er viele gehofft hatten dass es sich
noch vermieden vermeiden lassen würde
also die ganzen diplomatischen
bemühungen der letzten wochen und
monaten waren umsonst das ist seit heute
klar gestern hatten ganz offiziell die
prorussischen separatisten in den
rebellengebieten ja um hilfe gefragt und
putin hatte vor schon signalisiert dass
er diese truppen schicken würde und dann
ging in der tat alles ganz schnell und
wladimir putin hat hier im russischen
staatsfernsehen
ortszeit 5.30 wir sind wie zwei stunden
zeitunterschied zu europa also 33
deutscher zeit hat er in einem großen
monolog seine motivation erklärt und wir
haben ja noch alle die rede immer vor
drei tagen mit den hass tiraden richtung
ukraine mit dem absprechen der ukraine
für für das existenzrecht sozusagen und
da ist er auch immer noch mal genauer
drauf eingegangen ich kann da ein paar
dinge vielleicht noch mal zitieren erst
mal wurde klar dass in ihm eine tiefe
enttäuschung herrscht und ja alle eine
große abneigung gegenüber dem westen und
der nato er sagt zum beispiel als
reaktion auf unsere vorschläge waren wir
ständig entweder zynischen täuschungen
ausgesetzt lügen druck und
erpressungsversuchen das geht in
richtung nato und er sagt generell haben
wir den eindruck dass fast überall in
allen regionen der welt wo die
vereinigten staaten unterwegs waren dass
sie eigentlich da nur ein blutiges chaos
hinterlassen haben und geschwüre des
internationalen terrorismus und in dem
selbstverständnis geht er jetzt
sozusagen in die ukraine rein um da
wieder für ordnung zu sorgen er
beschimpft auch die ukrainische führung
erneut das seien alles neonazis und
alles fremd gesteuerte menschen und er
sagt zwar die pläne für den einzug in
die ukraine die würden nicht beinhalten
eine besatzung aber die meldung die wir
jetzt heute sehen die sprechen jedoch
eine ganz andere sprache
und womit muss die ukraine womit muss
die welt nun rechnen mit welchen
nächsten schritten russlands
das ist schwer zu sagen wir haben das
die letzten wochen und monaten immer
versucht vorauszusagen und
herauszufinden in welche richtung putin
genau gehen will und jetzt erleben wir
heute ein szenario das natürlich bekannt
war und es ist aber in seinen vollen
zügen auch hat es genauso stattgefunden
wenn es überlegen zum beispiel das
militärmanöver in belarus also nördlich
der ukrainischen grenze da wurde mir
gesagt nein das ist nur ein
militärmanöver und warum regt ihr euch
denn so auf wir üben doch hier nur und
dann wurde das militärmanöver kurzerhand
verlängert obwohl vorher behauptet wurde
dass die russischen truppen abziehen
würden und das war natürlich auch
zusätzlich zu den anderen szenarien auch
ein massives massives bedrohungsszenario
wenn wir dann eben kam eine neue
anmeldung anmeldung hören dass der
belarussische diktator lukaschenko sich
auch bereit erklärt russland jetzt zur
seite zu stehen dann weiß man einfach
ganz genau dass diese ganzen szenarien
und das leugnen dieser szenarien von
russischer seite seite dass das immer
falsch war und dass das alles glatt
gelungen war unterstützung gibt es von
belarus wie groß ist denn die
unterstützung überhaupt bei der
russischen bevölkerung für putin
vorgehen
das war in der tat sehr differenziert
würde ich sagen es gibt schon einige die
hier der staatspropaganda folgen wo
genau dieses bild gezeichnet wurde was
wäre die mir putin heute auch noch mal
beschrieben hat von der ukraine von
einem ja sozusagen von einem kaputten
start von einem kaputten system was von
einer extremistischen führung geleitet
wird dann gibt es wieder andere menschen
die konnten sich nicht wirklich
vorstellen dass man jetzt mit dem bruder
folgt sozusagen wirklich in einen krieg
zieht also viele russinnen und russen
sind ja familiär auch noch sehr stark
gebunden an die ukraine haben
ukrainische wurzeln und da konnten sich
die menschen nicht wirklich vorstellen
dass man da jetzt gegenseitig
aufeinander schießen wird aber ich
erinnere mich an ein interview was mit
einer frau hier auf der straße hatten
sie sagte ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
dass es krieg gibt aber wenn es einen
krieg gibt dann wird er auf jeden fall
blutig die eu hat nun noch härtere
sanktionen angekündigt wird dass
wladimir putin in irgendeiner weise
beeindrucken
also vielleicht mir putin ist ein
stratege und ich glaube für irgend kann
es ja nicht überraschend kommen dass
diese harten sanktionen jetzt kommen sie
waren ja auch angekündigt wird
entsprechende vorkehrungen getroffen
haben und in gewisser weise ist das auch
eingepreist worden die frage ist jetzt
eben wie genau diese sanktionen aussehen
und wie hart sie dann
sein umfeld ihn persönlich bestimmte
personen treffen werden und wie hat sie
vielleicht auch dann hier auf die
wirtschaft geht dann alles das
wichtigste was was putin endlich die
letzten jahre hier immer versucht hat
wir haben ja eine große repressionswelle
hier auch erlebt gegen die opposition
und gegen anders denkt und alle die
sozusagen gegen ihn waren waren seine
feinde und sein größtes ziel war immer
der machterhalt und wenn dir das land
jetzt sozusagen aus den fugen gerät weil
es für viele menschen wirtschaftlich
bergab geht dann könnte er natürlich
hier ein neues problem haben dass die
menschen gegen ihn auf die straße gehen
das sind heute bereits kleinere proteste
angekündigt worden eine
oppositionspolitikerin hat zu protesten
gegen diesen krieg aufgerufen die ist
nicht sonderlich bekannt diese
politikerin weil die meisten
oppositionspolitiker sitzen entweder im
gefängnis oder sind aus dem land gejagt
wurden christiansen vielen dank für
diese einschätzung vielen dank nach
moskau und meine damen und herren wir
sind jetzt per telefon mit meinem
kollegen axel sturm verbunden er hat die
vergangenen tage
aus kiew für uns berichtet musste aber
nun die ukrainische hauptstadt aus
sicherheitsgründen verlassen axel die
erste frage daher wie geht es ihnen und
konnten sie sich in sicherheit bringen
aber ich bin wohl auch gut aufwachsen
können sie leider nicht ganz so gut
verstehen aber vielleicht können sie uns
noch kurz beschreiben was passiert denn
da gerade in der hauptstadt was passiert
in kiew
naja vielleicht war es auch das
enttäuschung aber
und wir müssen an dieser stelle leider
dieses telefongespräch unterbrechen sie
haben es gehört oder vielmehr sie haben
nicht viel gehört weil leider die
verbindung sehr schlecht war aber wir
versuchen es natürlich nachher noch mal
live zu meinem kollegen axel sturm in
die ukraine zu schalten ja meine damen
und herren präsident putin hat er sich
am frühen morgen unserer zeit im
russischen fernsehen an sein volk
gewandt er sprach eine stunde lang und
erklärte warum ein angriff notwendig sei
doch die rede war auch an die welt
adressiert putin warnte andere staaten
sich russland in den weg zu stellen
nicht in den weg zu stellen denn das
würde konsequenzen haben die sie noch
nicht erlebt hätten
die volksrepublik 'nimm don was wandten
sich mit der bitte um hilfe an russland
in diesem zusammenhang in
übereinstimmung mit artikel 51 des teils
7 der un-charta mit zustimmung des
föderationsrates von russland wurde in
übereinstimmung mit den freundschafts
und gegenseitigen beistand verträgen die
von der bundesversammlung am 22 februar
dieses jahres mit dem volksrepublik dann
jetzt und lugansk ratifiziert wurden
habe ich beschlossen eine spezielle
militär operation durchzuführen
ihr ziel ist es menschen zu schützen die
seit acht jahren mobbing und völkermord
durch das cover regime ausgesetzt sind
und dafür werden wir uns für die
entmilitarisierung und entnazifizierung
der ukraine einsetzen und diejenigen vor
gericht stellen die zahlreiche blutige
verbrechen gegen zivilisten
einschließlich bürger der russischen
föderation begangen haben gleichzeitig
behalten unsere pläne nicht die
besetzung ukrainischer gebiete wir
werden niemand etwas mit gewalt
aufzwingen die heutigen ereignisse sind
nicht mit dem wunsch verbunden die
interessen der ukraine und des
ukrainischen volkes zu verletzen sie
sind mit dem schutz russlands selbst vor
denen verbunden die die ukraine als
geisel genommen haben und versuchen sie
gegen unser land und sein volk
einzusetzen
ich wiederhole unsere handlungen sind
selbstverteidigung und gegen die
bedrohung die für uns geschaffen werden
und gegen eine noch größere katastrophe
als das was heute passiert egal wie
schwierig ist auch sein mag ich bitte
sie dies zu verstehen und rufen sie zur
zusammenarbeit auf um diese tragische
seite so schnell wie möglich
umzuschlagen und gemeinsam voranzukommen
um niemanden zu erlauben sich in unsere
angelegenheiten in unsere beziehungen
einzumischen
sondern um sie aus eigener kraft
aufzubauen damit sie die notwendigen
voraussetzungen zur überwindung aller
probleme schafft und uns trotz
vorhandener staatsgrenzen insgesamt von
innen stärken würde daran glaube ich
darin liegt unsere zukunft
nun ein paar wichtige sehr wichtige
worte für diejenigen die versucht sein
könnten den laufenden ereignisse
einzugreifen wer auch immer versucht uns
zu behindern und noch mehr bedrohungen
für unser land für unser volk zu
schaffen sollte wissen dass die reaktion
russlands sofort erfolgen und sie zu
solchen konsequenzen führen wird die sie
in ihrer geschichte noch nie erlebt
haben wir sind bereit für jede
entwicklung von ereignissen alle
diesbezüglich notwendigen entscheidungen
wurden getroffen ich hoffe dass ich
gehört wurde und
meine damen und herren in diesen minuten
erreicht uns die eilmeldung die ukraine
hat ihre diplomatischen beziehungen zu
russland abgebrochen
das teilte präsidentin seelands gemäht
er ruft die russinnen und russen auf
herauszukommen und gegen den krieg zu
protestieren
der präsident appellierte zudem an die
menschen ehrliche informationen
zufrieden zu verbreiten und fügte hinzu
der feind habe schwere verluste erlitten
und jetzt schalten wir live nach
washington zu meinem kollegen mrt wissen
er beobachtet dort die lage für uns
immer welche reaktionen gibt es denn
bereits von der us regierung
ja der us präsident hat sich der nach
dem statement geäußert er hat von einem
ungerechtfertigten angriff gesprochen
und von einem vorsätzlichen krieg durch
vladimir putin die welt werde russland
dafür zur rechenschaft ziehen so sagte
er hat auch mit dem ukrainischen
präsidenten
selensky dann telefoniert hat ihm
unterstützung zugesagt und das die
aufmerksamkeit hier in washington
richtet sich momentan in erster linie
auf zwei punkte das eine ist das was
militärisch tatsächlich in der ukraine
passiert und da löst etwas sorge
ausbilder die man gesehen hat an der
grenze im dreiländereck zwischen belarus
russland und der ukraine über diesen
grenzübergang sind offen bei der nacht
sehr viele panzer in die ukraine hinein
gerollt und dafür eine straße direkt
nach kiew das hat im pentagon hier die
sorge ausgelöst dass möglicherweise
russland versuchen könnte kiew zu
besetzen um gewissermaßen die
ukrainische führung zu isolieren von
ihren truppen im osten des landes also
möglicherweise die regierung durch ein
marionettenregime zu ersetzen das ist
die sorge die manni hat und die andere
aufmerksamkeit liegt auf den punkt der
sanktionen der us präsident wird sich
mit den g7 beraten aber auch dann hier
von washington aus die amerikanischen
sanktionen verkünden und die sollen sehr
oft seien es wird ja immer darüber
spekuliert hätte man nicht vorher diese
sanktionen verhängen sollen um putin
abzuschrecken die wahrheit so sagt man
hier im weißen haus man hatte keine
einigkeit in den letzten monaten über
sanktionen es wäre nicht möglich gewesen
diese geschlossenheit zu demonstrieren
und die kann man jetzt demonstrieren
wenn putin heute abend sieht das nicht
nur europa sondern auch die nato und
viele andere länder rund um den erdball
geschlossen das verurteilen was passiert
ist dann so ist das kalkül des weißen
hauses werden die sanktionen die dann
verhängt werden entsprechend auch
wirkung entfalten die ukraine ist ja
kein nato-mitglied welche unterstützung
plant us-präsident beiden ländern
ja es wird für die ukraine in dreierlei
hinsicht unterstützung geben das eine
ist geld das braucht die ukraine
sicherlich in so einer krisensituation
sowohl für die versorgung der
bevölkerung als auch möglicherweise für
den nachschub für das militär das ist
der zweite punkt die usa wollen und
werden weiter waffen und munition
liefern sofern das die lage am boden
tatsächlich in der ukraine erlaubt und
das dritte ist dass man auch
informationen weitergeben will aus der
aufklärung der vereinigten staaten aus
satelliten aus auch von
aufklärungsflügen über die ukraine um
auf diese weise in der lage zu sein die
ukrainischen streitkräfte in ihrem kampf
gegen die russischen truppen zu
unterstützen elmar theveßen vielen dank
vielen dank nach washington ja meine
damen und herren es ist also geschehen
von dem alle gehofft hatten dass es
nicht eintreten würde trotz aller
beteuerung hat russland einen
großangriff auf die ukraine gestartet in
mehreren städten waren explosionen zu
hören russische truppen greifen offenbar
auch aus richtung belarus ann katrin
noack fast für uns zusammen
aus drohungen und ankündigungen hat
präsident putin und fakten gemacht
bilder aus charkiw in der nacht sollen
erste angriffe zeigen notwendige
angriffe wie er meint ich habe die
entscheidung für eine militär operation
getroffen um menschen zu schützen die
seit acht jahren in einem völkermord
durch das regime in kiew ausgesetzt
waren bis zum ende streben wir eine
entmilitarisierung und enden
akzeptierung der ukraine an außerdem
werden wir die zur rechenschaft ziehen
die verbrechen an der zivilbevölkerung
begangen haben einschließlich 1 bürgern
der russischen föderation deutliche
worte auch in richtung anderer länder
wer auch immer versucht uns zu stoppen
oder unser land bedroht der sollte
wissen dass russlands antwort schnell
sein wird und konsequenzen hat solche
die es in der geschichte so noch nie gab
wir sind zu allem bereit
nach und nach gibt es immer mehr bilder
der angriffe diese sollen dem
militärflughafen in chur aufzeigen
russland behauptet diesen zerstört zu
haben ähnliche bilder auch vom flughafen
in mario pohl der hafenstadt am
schwarzen meer auch die stadt selbst
soll angegriffen worden sein als
reaktion verhängte der ukrainische
präsident lenski das kriegsrecht in
einer videobotschaft schafft rief er
seine landsleute dazu auf nicht in panik
zu verfallen
wir sind stark und auf alles vorbereitet
wir werden siegen
der ukrainische botschafter in
deutschland warnt und bittet zugleich im
morgenmagazin des zdf
es ist jetzt an der zeit uns zur seite
zu stellen wenn die ukraine fällt dann
ist europa als nächstes opfer dabei dass
das muss man so leider sehen und
deswegen wir brauchen auch jetzt
unterstützung für die verteidigung um
die menschen zu schützen denn die
ukrainische armee ist zwar bereit aber
aber wir sind natürlich da nach wie vor
in einer position wo wir vor einem sehr
mächtigen gegner stehen auch diese
ukrainische militärstützpunkt soll ziel
von raketen geworden sein ein soldat
fordert die menschen auf die gegend zu
verlassen
sie können jederzeit wieder zuschlagen
sie müssen sofort weg hier
genau das versuchen viele bilder aus
kiew zeigen lange staus raus aus der
stadt nur wohin ist die frage
und werden jetzt die möglichkeit mit
egon ramms zu sprechen er ist ehemaliger
nato-general der general ich begrüße sie
vielen dank dass sie für uns die zeit
haben an diesem ganz besonderen tag wir
hören ist soll nicht nur angriffe aus
der luft geben sondern auch bodentruppen
eingesetzt werden wie bewerten sie das
also ich möchte zunächst einmal ganz
kurz auf die geräte von putin eingehen
die heute nacht gehalten hat für diese
aktion die er jetzt eingeleitet hat den
artikel 51 der charta der vereinten
nationen zu zitieren ich schon eine
ausgesprochene frechheit
jetzt zu ihrer frage
sieht so aus das hatte ich in dieser
form nicht erwartet als wenn die ukraine
tatsächlich von drei seiten angegriffen
würde nämlich im osten im norden und
möglicherweise auch truppen gebunden
werden unten über die krim was mich
überrascht hat ist der angriff aus
belarus raus der richtung norden das
praktisch
kiew unmittelbar bedroht und das könnte
eine entsprechende entwicklung nehmen
die in dieser form vielleicht nicht
vorherzusehen war
meine erwartung ist gewesen dass es über
lugansk und donny es gehen würde und
dass man von dort aus entsprechend den
angriff durchführen würde um dann die
gesamten region oder ob laste in diesem
bereich in die hand zu bekommen und dass
es danach weitergehen würde das was
passiert ist mit blick auf die angriffe
offensichtlich auf militär ziele wobei
man bei diesem urteil um immer noch sehr
vorsichtig sein muss
so deutet darauf dass man versuchen will
die luftwaffe der ukraine festzunageln
am boden damit sie nicht in die kämpfe
eingreifen kann und wenn solche angriffe
beispielsweise auch auf militärische
einrichtungen kasernenanlagen von ihre
streitkräfte erfolgt sind dann wird man
hier ein ähnliches ziel verfolgen das
heißt putin oder die angreifenden kräfte
wollen verhindern dass die ukrainischen
streitkräfte ordnungsgemäß eingesetzt
werden können zur verteidigung präsident
seelands die hat ja versucht in einer
videobotschaft der ukrainischen
bevölkerung mut zuzusprechen er meinte
man solle nicht in panik verfallen und
man werde wegen da weiß er doch
eigentlich selbst dass das unrealistisch
ist oder
das kann ich so nicht beurteilen ich
halte die ukrainische streitkräfte im
heutigen zustand eigentlich für sehr
kampf- kräftig und auch die soldaten
sind offensichtlich gewillt wie auch die
masse der bevölkerung ihr vaterland zu
verteidigen gegen diesen angriff von
russland und von daher muss man abwarten
wie sich das entwickelt die
erfolgsmeldung die jetzt möglicherweise
auch von russischer seite in den
nächsten stunden veröffentlicht werden
gehören zur allgemeinen
desinformation die russland ja auch
schon den letzten tagen betrieben hat
für mich war montagabend klar dass der
einsatz der streitkräfte der russischen
streitkräfte erfolgen wurde nur wusste
zu dem zeitpunkt niemand wo das
tatsächlich losgehen würde und jetzt
zeichnen sich nach meinem dafürhalten
zwei schwerpunkte ab einmal im norden
und einmal im osten herr general wären
es eben kann das schon ein wenig
angedeutet welche pläne verfolgt putin
nun langfristig was
erreichen ist ihre einschätzen
was ich verweise auf seine rede vom
montagabend und ich verweise auch auf
einen artikel den er im vergangenen jahr
geschrieben hat der dazu sehr
interessante aussagen enthält er will
offensichtlich das alte dreieck russland
belarus ukraine wieder herstellen und
damit praktisch groß russen weißrussen
und kleinbussen wieder unter einem dach
bringen um damit auf die entsprechende
russische macht wieder hinzuweisen er
hat ja öfter vorher schon von gross
große ja gesprochen und er hat ja vorher
auch schon gesagt dass die dass die
auflösung der sowjetunion der größte
fehler des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
gewesen soll wie sollte die nato nun
reagieren das denken sie
also die nato kann ja im augenblick
nicht reagieren und sie sollte auch
nicht reagieren indem sie tatsächlich
kampfhandlungen eingreift die nato hat
bereits verlegt kräfte in die baltischen
staaten zusätzliche kräfte in die
baltischen staaten und nach polen auch
nach rumänien von daher ist ein zeichen
gesetz einfach in der richtung dass in
dem augenblick wo die nato grenzen
überschritten werden die nato dann auch
militärisch handeln kann mehr ist
eigentlich im raum liegt nicht möglich
die nato muss weiterhin auch in dieser
situation geschlossen bleiben das ist ja
eine wichtige punkt dabei und der zweite
wichtige punkt aber ist das datum und eu
so häufig in der zukunft auch weiter mit
einer stimme sprechen sie haben die
geschlossenheit der nato angesprochen
selten war sich die nato einig das wird
vermutlich nicht das gewesen sein was
putin gebaut hat oder
das ist sicherlich eines der
strategischen ziele die er sich so nicht
vorgestellt hat
für ihn wäre es einfacher wenn er in der
lage wäre zwischen die nato staaten und
zwischen die eu-staaten einen keil
dazwischen zu treiben und dann praktisch
zu versuchen den vorteil für sich
auszunutzen das ist ihm bisher nicht
gelungen und ich hoffe dass das auch so
bleibt herr general eine letzte frage
wird sich deutschland dennoch weiter
gegen waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
sperren können ist das richtig in ihren
augen
das ist eine frage die muss in der an
die bundesregierung gestellt werden
nicht allein ehemaligen deutschen
general
ich würde mir wünschen dass diese
haltung zumindest mit blick auf
defensivwaffen aufgegeben wird um auf
diese art und weise auch aus einer
bestimmten ecke sage ich mal in der
wahrnehmung durch die anderen nato und
die eu staaten herauszukommen man kann
ein land weg ist in einer solch
schwierigen situation ist nicht ohne
weiteres alleine stehen lassen wobei ich
auch da noch waren den finger heben
möchte und darauf hinweisen möchte dass
wir auch aufpassen müssen dass wir da
aber nicht kriegspartei werden die
einschätzung von egon ramms vielen dank
und aus brüssel gibt es nun reaktion der
nato aus der nachdruck von der eu am
morgen fragen danach bei gruner krüger
in brüssel zunächst zur nato dort hat
sich generalsekretär
stoltenberg geäußert
ja nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg hat
sich heute nacht in einem statement
geäußert zumindest erst mal schriftlich
offensichtlich hat man dem
nato-hauptquartier in brüssel nicht
geschlafen ungefähr gegen 4 uhr kam die
nachricht mit einem wortlaut wie wir ihn
auch in washington oder auch in brüssel
hier bei der kommission hören nämlich
mit denselben adjektiven die da sind
nicht gerechtfertigt nicht provoziert
also ungerechtfertigt und provoziert
soll heißen man wert genau dieselben
worte man lässt nicht einmal haarrisse
in dem westlichen bündnissen erkennen
und stolberg wird heute nochmal vor die
presse treten um 12 uhr zurzeit tagten
die botschafter ganz interessant in
dieser ersten schriftlichen
stellungnahme die ja heute morgen
verbreitet hat da ist am ende ein satz
der eben aufhorchen lässt da steht noch
einmal ganz deutlich drin die nato wird
alles tun um ihre bündnispartner zu
verteidigen punkt und in diesem punkt da
schließt sich ein bisschen der kreis
putin führt diesen krieg ja damit die
ukraine nie mitglied der nato wird und
wir müssen aus diesem punkt auch aus
lesen dass die nato in diesen krieg
nicht eingreifen wird eben weil die
ukraine kein mitglied der nato ist heute
morgen hat dann auch eu
kommissionspräsidenten ursula von der
leyen gesprochen soll ein eu gipfel
geben wie reagierte die europäische
union auf die russische aggression
ja man muss ja erst mal feststellen dass
die eu also die europäische union die
sich ja immer als das große
friedensprojekt für europa verstanden
hat dass die heute morgen aufgewacht ist
mit dem wahnsinn des krieges vor ihrer
haustür das also all die bemühungen der
letzten wochen und monate am ende keinen
erfolg hatten dass die sanktionen die
man angedroht hat und die ganze
diplomatie die man gemacht hat dass das
eben la die mir putin nicht nicht davon
abgehalten hat diesen angriff auf die
ukraine zu fahren und nun werden die
staats und regierungschefs heute abend
in einem präsenz gipfel ab 20 uhr
gelegenheit haben über ihre politik zu
diskutieren ob das nun eben nur ein
misserfolg war oder ob es sogar ein
fehler war diese ganzen anstrengungen zu
machen auf jeden fall wird die eu
kommissionspräsidenten ursula von der
leyen in ein weiteres sanktionspaket
vorschlagen es ist angekündigte sei das
größte was die eu jeweils vorgeschlagen
hat es sei ein massives paket an
sanktionen und von der leyen hat schon
verraten dass dort auch weitere
russische banken gelistet werden sollen
die dann vom internationalen
zahlungsverkehr abgeschnitten werden
sollen interessant wird dann tatsächlich
die frage sein ob auch ein exportstopp
für hochtechnologie seitens der eu
gegenüber russland verhängt werden
sollte so ein exportstopp der würde dann
eben auch einzelne mitgliedsstaaten
stark treffen zb den maschinenbau in
deutschland oder in italien und das wäre
dann ein echter test für die einheit der
eu unter krueger live aus brüssel vielen
dank und
meine damen und herren ich bin nicht
mehr alleine hier im studio sind ich
begrüße jetzt den politikwissenschaftler
professor karl rudolf korte
morgen professor konnte die frage
zunächst hat man wladimir putin
unterschätzt die bundesregierung ist in
der startphase sehr intensiv von anfang
an auf internationale themen auch
gegangen
wir haben eher die erzählung dass es um
die interne transformation geht und
modernisierungsschub aus einer
nachhaltigkeit gesellschaft hier zu
schaffen aber gleichzeitig sind auch
internationale formate wiederbelebt
worden auch in den letzten tagen das was
also die bundesregierung auszeichnet
solidarität herzustellen
institutionen mit kommunikation auch zu
füllen und zu beleben ich kann nicht
erkennen dass das nicht genutzt worden
ist was hätte die deutsche außenpolitik
vielleicht auch in den letzten jahren
anders machen sollen oder müssen die
deutsche außenpolitik ist natürlich
zunächst mal eine die an der mit der eu
ausgerichtet und orientiert ist und
insofern ging es immer darum die
intensivierung einer gemeinsamen
position der europäer zu entwickeln das
war auch unter dem gesichtspunkt dass
transatlantisch auszuweiten unter der
präsidentschaft von trump sehr schwer
und wir müssen wir uns ehrlich machen
innenpolitisch spielen diese themen
keine rolle die sicherheits deutschen
die auch sicherheitsorientiert wählen
interessieren sich nicht intensiv für
internationale auseinandersetzung hier
ist nie eine große diskussion gewesen
über deutsches internationales
engagement sowohl militärisch als auch
diplomatisch wir sind da eher im
schneckenhaus insofern zwar die
bundesregierung agiert aber wir wollten
damit uns nicht wirklich
auseinandersetzen ist eine reine
gefasste gelassenheit geradezu zu
internationalen themen und indem wir uns
zurückgezogen haben und das fällt
natürlich jetzt auf uns zurück immer
wieder kommen einzelne themen hoch wie
die frage
schickt man jetzt panzer oder schickt
man sie nicht so das sind einzelne
themen die aber tagesereignisse sind
aber nicht grundsätzlich in der
bevölkerung diskutiert worden sind es
fällt jetzt auf die regierung zurück das
heißt welche möglichkeiten gibt es denn
nun das kann jetzt noch getan werden ja
einmal erinnere ich mich an die
konstellation neue bundesregierung
rot-grün schröder/fischer der
kosovo-krieg ganz frische neue regierung
zwei oppositionsparteien mit krieg
konfrontiert damals bürgerkrieg ganz
andere dimension ist das diesmal
aber wieder haben wir eine neue
bundesregierung diesmal als ampel
regierung die frische am abend noch
nichtmals 100 tage mit diesen neuen
europäischen krieg konfrontiert wird und
da kann man jetzt nicht einfach auf
routine setzen das ist nicht nicht in
der bundesregierung verhandelt außerdem
bei den sozialdemokraten die immer schon
mit regiert haben aber doch auf eine
erfahrung die man anknüpfen kann und das
ist zunächst mal das was wir an
gesprächs elementen haben kommunikation
als das wichtigste instrument
solidarität mit anderen herzustellen
sich abzustimmen und die gesellschaft
ist in einer vielfach krise sehen wir
wir haben ja nicht nur corona jetzt den
krieg und unter diesen rahmenbedingungen
schafft die bundesregierung ist nur
schwer eigentlich auch tritt zu fassen
zu den themen die sie im
koalitionsvertrag aus formuliert hat
also wir haben den alltag von vielfach
krisen wie werden wir so
widerstandsfähig in der gesellschaft in
der demokratie auch außenpolitisch dass
wir mit allem was auf uns zukommt
zukünftig aktiv werden das ist
eigentlich die schlussfolgerung die wir
jetzt treffen müssen welche
instrumentarien müssen wir für einen
klugen vorsorge staat entwickeln dass
wir nicht nur überrascht werden sondern
dass wir auch handlungsfähig bleibt bei
diesen gang in vielen krisen vielleicht
können sie es auch nochmal erklären wenn
sich der einzelne deutsche nun fragt was
geht mich eigentlich die ukraine an also
da hat die außenministerin sehr treffend
formuliert unser leben hat sich mit
heute verändert es gibt praktisch eine
neue zeitrechnung wir können mit neuen
müssen neuen migrations
flüchtlingsströmen rechnen wir müssen
mit versorgungssicherheit im
elementarsten bereich uns
auseinandersetzen
energieversorgung mit preisen vielleicht
auch für nahrungsmittel also unser leben
im alltag ist betroffen unmittelbar
nicht unmittelbar jetzt aber in die
nächste zeit denn der krieg wird ja
nicht kurz dauern sondern länger
anhalten insofern ist das ein ein ja ein
einschnitt für uns alle den wir nicht
als zuschauer beobachten sondern der hat
rückwirkungen auf unser alltagsleben
auch auf unsere demokratie
keine frage auch zum schluss wer hat
denn überhaupt noch einfluss auf den
russischen präsidenten fünf jahres nicht
ob sie das einschätzen können aber
welche rolle spielt dabei auch china die
chinesische meldung heute irritieren
denn das klingt wie eine zuschauerrolle
die die chinesen wahrnehmen neutral du
sie verurteilen putin nicht nehmen noch
nicht vollständig in schutz aber sie
stellen eine ganz eigene sonderrolle da
und insofern sehen wir wie sich
machtverhältnisse offenbar international
verändert haben aber die möglichkeiten
die noch bestehen können aus unserer
sicht ja nur darin bestehen und sich mit
anderen abzustimmen also die
kommunikation als solches auch wenn die
gegenseite schießt ist zunächst mal das
was die qualität unserer demokratie
ausmacht und das mit anderen solidarisch
herzustellen ist auch ein teil durchaus
schon der problemlösung der mit anderen
kann man dann andere initiativen auch
ergreifen man ist nicht da ja momentan
sehr einig denken sie denn dass diese
einigkeit auch anhalten wird von dauer
sein wird normalerweise diszipliniert so
etwas ungeheuer und wird denke ich sehr
stark und auch nachhaltig die
gemeinsamkeiten stärken in den bündnis
strukturen die da sind und wir müssen
trotzdem drüber nachdenken inwieweit wir
neue institutionelle formate entwickeln
müssen die osten entspannungs politik
damals auch von der bundesregierung der
70er jahre massiv mit unterstützt hat ja
dazu geführt auch ganz neue
internationale organisationen zu gründen
kasse die osze in solche formate zuletzt
nach 1989 19 der deutschen
wiedervereinigung sind auch neue
institutionen nicht also welche neue
internationalen formate müssen wir
angesichts der neuen herausforderung
offenbar aus prägen werden wir nachher
in der idee naja ich glaube man muss
intensiv auch über trilaterale formate
nachdenken dass am tag der
kriegserklärung sehr schwer aber
trilaterale zwischen russland china und
den usa denn die chinesen müssen
offenbar gleichgewichtig mit betrachtet
werden und wir wissen eigentlich aus der
erfahrung dass langfristige
friedenssicherung er auch im sinne des
völkerbundes davon ausgehen in einem
gespräch zu bleiben das klingt an dem
tag etwas kurios wenn einer zu den
waffen greift aber auf lange sicht hatte
sich bewährt unter bündnis strategien
augenhöhe herzustellen und nicht einen
partner zu vermitteln er ist weniger
wert oder ist in der defensive viele der
kriege sind entstanden aus vielen der
falsche antizipation der wahrnehmung des
anderen dass wir zu wenig über den
anderen wussten wir über uns denkt und
aus solchen viel wahrnehmungen entstehen
oft krisen und kriege und deswegen
fehlwahrnehmung zu beheben geht nur
durch gespräche die kommunikation durch
austausch durch bündnis professor konnte
gut dass sie hierbei unter studios sind
schön dass sie da denn während rechen
gleich bestimmt noch mal meine damen und
herren auch die politik in berlin ist
von den entwicklungen in der ukraine
aufs höchste alarmiert deutsche
staatsbürger wo dringender aufgerufen
das land möglichst schnell zu verlassen
außenministerin werde kündigte nach
einer sitzung des krisenstabs im
auswärtigen amt schärfste sanktionen an
bundesinnenministerium feser twitterte
zu auswirkungen dieses russischen
angriffskrieges auf die sicherheitslage
in deutschland und auf fluchtbewegungen
europa sind wir äußerst wachsam und
vorbereitet die sicherheitsbehörden
haben sich auf alle szenarien
vorbereitet und schutzmaßnahmen
hochgefahren und am nachmittag berät das
sicherheitskabinett der bundesregierung
im kanzleramt
in berlin tagt 10 uhr das
sicherheitskabinett kurz zuvor tritt die
außenministerin noch vor die presse
dieser krieg soll vor allem eins
zerstören die hoffnung der menschen in
der ukraine
dass sie nach jahrzehnten der unfreiheit
ein recht auf demokratie ein recht auf
frieden und auf eine bessere zukunft
ohne unterdrückung haben
präsident putin diesen traum werden sie
niemals zerstören können er wächst in
der ukraine
er wächst genau so in ihrem land auch
die deutsche verteidigungsministerin
wendet sich heute direkt an den
russischen präsidenten putin tritt
völkerrecht mit füßen und nimmt
unfassbares leid in auch in kauf um
seine großmacht fantasien zu befriedigen
das muss ein ende haben wir müssen
geschlossen stehen in der nato in der eu
und jetzt muss es ganz schnell wirksame
konsequente sanktionen geben es muss
klar sein team die nato die eu stehen
geschlossen zusammen wir stehen zu
unseren verbündeten ziehen sie ihre
truppen zurück sofort die diplomatischen
bemühungen die sanktionsdrohung der
letzten wochen vergeblich vizekanzler
harbeck spricht von einem angriffskrieg
auf ein souveränes land und zeigt sich
selbstkritisch aber
diese aktionen waren eigentlich dazu
gedacht ist nicht zum krieg kommen zu
lassen und es war ein drohpotenzial von
dem putin ahnen konnte dass es hart
werden wird und das wird es auch werden
aber es hätte natürlich nicht vom krieg
abgehalten rückblickend muss man sagen
wenn man sich die schriften von putin
aus dem letzten sommer anschaut wenn man
die wortbeiträge zusammen schneidet das
der westen europa deutschland zu naiv
aus der opposition signale der
geschlossenheit sie die eu-chefs märz
verspricht der regierung unterstützung
es gehe um die verteidigung unserer
freiheit wir sollten hier auch
innenpolitisch sehr klar und deutlich
sagen wir werden jede maßnahme
unterstützen auch als union die darauf
ausgerichtet ist dass nato territorium
vor weiteren übergriffen
russlands zu schützen wenn notwendig
auch militärisch deutschland will sich
jetzt international mit der eu der nato
sowie den stärksten wirtschaftsmächten
im g7 format abstimmen die rede ist
schon jetzt vom härtesten sanktionspaket
das je erhoben wurde
und wir schalten live nach berlin zu
meinem kollegen thomas reichert thomas
energisch reagiert die bundesregierung
auf das was da gerade in der ukraine
passiert was ist ihr eindruck
mein eindruck ist dass sie sehr
energisch und auch durchaus vorbereitet
darauf reagiert da ist auf der einen
seite natürlich ein gehöriges maß an
fassungslosigkeit dass putin tatsächlich
diese in version macht dass er alle
diplomatischen gesten und handreichungen
für eine friedliche lösung aus der hand
geschlagen hat der eindruck hier ist
dass das ein kalt geplante aktion ist
auf der anderen seite gut vorbereitet
insofern als dass sanktionspaket das
heute nachmittag mit den eu-partnern
verkündet werden soll schon seit wochen
vorbereitet ist dass das haben gab es
lange vorbereitungen der iss ist ein
scharfes schwert weil es eben das
bankwesen und das finanzwesen trifft im
moment tag das sicherheitskabinett das
trifft nur das tritt wirklich nur in
außergewöhnlichen situation zusammen
gegen 11 uhr 30 also in etwa 15 minuten
erwarten die eine stellungnahme von
bundeskanzler olaf scholz und gerade
eben hören wir dass am sonntag ist eine
sondersitzung des bundestages geben wird
dass also die bundesregierung in einer
regierungserklärung die abgeordneten
informieren will über die handlungen der
bundesregierung und über die
einschätzungen dieser neuen dramatischen
lage
kanzlers holz hat der ukraine volle
solidarität zugesichert was bedeutet das
denn genau also wie weit wird diese
solidarität gehen
sie wird sicher nicht dahin gehen dass
das deutschland mit truppen oder mit
offensiven waffen hilft als teil der
nato wird das nicht passieren und auch
die haltung zu direkten
waffenlieferungen ist nach wie vor tun
ist offiziell die dass das nicht
passieren wird es ist trotzdem etwas
bewegung in berlin in die frage gekommen
ob man die ukraine nicht sonst mit
material auch mit militärischem material
unterstützen kann
infolge dieser dieser invasion das wird
man sehen aber die wesentliche hilfe
sind möglicherweise finanzhilfen weitere
finanzhilfen und sanktionen gegen
russland von denen man hofft dass sie
lade mir putin tatsächlich weh tun auch
wenn man hier in berlin weiß dass putin
diesen angriff seit langem vorbereitet
hat und deswegen auch in der lage ist
sanktionen auch scharfe sanktionen der
eu für eine weile auszuhalten trotzdem
die hoffnung ist auch hier in berlin
dass die sanktionen an den die so scharf
sind dass sie putin doch schmerzen
werden auch wenn die geschichte von
sanktionen in internationalen
beziehungen da nur begrenzt hoffnung
gibt dass es eine verhaltensänderung
dass hier eine verhaltensänderung
bewirken können wie einig ist man sich
denn insgesamt im politischen berlin
über das weitere vorgehen also auch
nicht nur die regierungsparteien
also da gibt es jetzt in dieser in
dieser dramatischen notsituation ein
großes zusammenrücken das war schon in
den letzten tagen zu beobachten haben
heute früh friedrich merz gehört der der
bundesregierung unterstützung zugesagt
hat auch in den tagen zuvor war aus der
union lob für die handlungen der
bundesregierung zu hören keine kritik
sondern auch der hinweis dass man sich
nun in dieser situation hinter der
bundesregierung versammeln sollen
ähnlich ist es heute früh sogar von der
afg zu hören die ebenfalls den einmarsch
putins in der ukraine verurteilt hat
auch da gibt es zumindest in den
verlautbarungen eine art heranrücken das
ist eine besondere situation und ich
kann mein eindruck ist dass es sozusagen
die naivität von der robert habeck heute
schon gesprochen hat dass die eben nun
in einer art bösen erwachen hier in
berlin endet und dass man das gefühl hat
wir können diese situation diese krise
tatsächlich nur gemeinsam meistern zu
beobachten ist noch mal da ein
deutliches zusammenrücken und erstmal
keine kritik an der bundesregierung die
deutsch russische gaspipeline nord
stream 2 wurde ja vorerst gestoppt kann
man denn das vorerst jetzt streichen
nach diesen tag
also da war es interessant auch robert
habeck heute früh zu hören er hat sich
da ein bisschen herumgedrückt um eine
klare antwort das hat aber aus meiner
sicht vor allem auch damit zu tun dass
ein klare absage an nordstream zwei
technisch möglicherweise hohe kosten für
die für die bundesregierung bedeuten
würde der versuch ist sozusagen eine
entziehung dieser oder den rückzug des
versorgungs sicherheitsbericht es zu
versuchen ist insofern eleganter und
einfacher und die bundesregierung
vertritt zumindest im moment die meinung
dass man sozusagen eine endgültige
entscheidung über notruf ein moment noch
gar nicht treffen will klar ist diese
entscheidung am
montag war eine relativ klare deutliche
und sie kann sehr schnell ohne großes
zögern und deswegen wird man jetzt erst
einmal diesen sozusagen bürokratischen
weg wählen zu sagen der versorgungs
sicherheitsberichte zunächst abgegeben
wurde von der alten regierung der großen
koalition ist aufgrund der aktuellen
situation nicht mehr nicht mehr gegeben
deswegen haben wir ihn zurückgezogen und
natürlich wird man für die erstellung
eines neuen versorgen
sicherheitsberichts sich ausreichend
zeit lassen und nur 22 erst einmal
sozusagen einmotten
und deswegen ja ich glaube es wird
erstmal bei diesem vorläufigen
ausbleiben eine letzte wichtige frage es
ist zu erwarten dass menschen aus der
ukraine flüchten was ist da zu erwarten
und gibt es diesbezüglich vorbereitung
in deutschland
die innenministerin hat heute ihr schon
angekündigt dass man das beobachtet dass
man darauf vorbereitet sei ich glaube
dass es im moment noch etwas früh es
überhaupt zu sagen was da auf europa und
deutschland zukommt klar ist natürlich
dass das menschen sind die auch von
einer unmittelbaren kriegsgefahr vor
eine sorge um leib und leben fürchten
und
klar ist auch dass der sich das
sicherheitskabinett dass da jetzt eben
im kanzleramt arg sich genau mit diesen
fragen unter anderem beschäftigen wird
die wir wie geht man mit flüchtlingen um
wie geht man um dies mit der sicherheit
deutscher die noch in der ukraine sind
um wie kann man denen helfen es ist im
moment glaube ich zu diesem zeitpunkt
noch zu früh zu sagen wohin genau da die
reise gehen wird vielen dank thomas
reichert vielen dank nach berlin und
meine damen und herren und erreicht so
eben diese meldung bislang sollen im
zusammenhang mit dem an 40 menschen
getötet worden sein das gab ein berater
des ukrainischen präsidenten zielinsky
bekannt 40 tote ja und meine damen und
herren es ist also geschehen von dem
alle gehofft hatten dass es nicht
eintreten würde trotz aller beteuerung
hat russland einen großangriff auf die
ukraine gestartet in mehreren städten
waren explosionen zu hören russische
truppen greifen offenbar auch aus
richtung belarus an karin noack fast das
ganze für uns zusammen
absperrband um die reste einer rakete in
einer straße von kiew am frühen morgen
war sie hier eingeschlagen die anwohner
immer noch fassungslos
ich wohne gleich da drüben es war eine
unglaublich starke explosion ich hatte
panik und rannte nach draußen
überall sirenen und die alarmanlagen der
autos greifen
in der nacht hatte präsident putin aus
drohungen und ankündigungen fakten
gemacht bilder aus hartz iv sollen erste
angriffe zeigen notwendige angriffe so
sieht es putin ich habe die entscheidung
für eine militär operation getroffen um
menschen zu schützen die seit acht
jahren einem völkermord durch das regime
in kiew ausgesetzt waren bis zum ende
streben wir eine entmilitarisierung und
entnazifizierung der ukraine an außerdem
werden wir die zur rechenschaft ziehen
die verbrechen an der zivilbevölkerung
begangen haben nach und nach gibt es
immer mehr bilder der angriffe diese
sollen dem militärflughafen in zukunft
zeigen russland behauptet diesen
zerstört zu haben ähnliche bilder auch
vom flughafen in mario pohl der
hafenstadt am schwarzen meer auch die
stadt selbst soll angegriffen worden
sein als reaktion verhängte der
ukrainische präsident selensky das
kriegsrecht in einer videobotschaft rief
er seine landsleute dazu auf nicht in
panik zu verfallen wir sind stark und
auf alles vorbereitet wir werden siegen
der ukrainische botschafter in
deutschland warnt und bittet im
morgenmagazin des zdf
es ist jetzt an der zeit uns zur seite
zu stellen wenn die ukraine fällt dann
ist europa als nächstes opfer dabei dass
das muss man so leider sehen und
deswegen wir brauchen auch jetzt
unterstützung für die verteidigung um
die menschen zu schützen denn die
ukrainische armee ist zwar bereit aber
aber wir sind natürlich da nach wie vor
in einer position wo wir auf einem sehr
mächtigen gegner stehen auch dieser
ukrainische militärstützpunkt soll ziel
von raketen geworden sein ein soldat
fordert die menschen auf die gegend zu
verlassen
sie können jederzeit wieder zuschlagen
sie müssen sofort weg hier
genau das versuchen bilder aus kiew
zeigen lange staus raus aus der stadt
nur wohin ist die frage
und für 11 uhr 30 also in etwa acht
minuten hat bundeskanzler scholz eine
pressekonferenz angekündigt er wird ein
statement abgeben zu der aktuellen lage
in der ukraine hier sehen sie live
bilder aus dem bundeskanzleramt wir
werden ihnen diese pressekonferenz
selbstverständlich dann gleich live
zeigen und jetzt schalten wir zu meiner
kollegin sienna meinet an die
frankfurter börse sina wie reagiert denn
die börse auf diese aktuellen ereignisse
wie wir sicherlich alle geschockt das
muss man wirklich sagen generell setzt
nicht nur die börse zunächst immer auf
eine friedliche und diplomatische lösung
und eben nicht auf eine derartige
eskalation konflikte dieser art sind wie
es so schön heißt nicht im system der
kapitalmärkte eingepreist damit kann
eben niemand rechnen dementsprechend
fallen die kursverluste weltweit aus an
der börse in moskau wurde der handel
heute zwischenzeitlich ausgesetzt
zeitweise 40 prozent im minus auch die
börsen in tokio und london haben massiv
nachgegeben und rutschen tief ins minus
und natürlich auch hier in frankfurt an
der börse verliert der dax aktuell
über viereinhalb prozent 13
1960 punkte also unter die 14.000 der
marke ist er gerutscht heute morgen
sagte ein händler die schlimmsten
befürchtungen sind wahr geworden es
herrscht krieg in europa und wir haben
es ja eben gerade gehört derzeit schon
mit 40 toten und wie reagiert die
deutsche wirtschaft darauf den
kriegsausbruch der die deutsche
wirtschaft wird in mitleidenschaft
gezogen gegen russland werden sanktionen
verhängt nun muss man aber sagen
sanktionen schaden eben auch immer
demjenigen der sie verhängt und auf der
nennen wir es einmal sanktions leiter
sind nun einige stufen übersprungen
worden der handel mit russland wird
eingeschränkt er macht zwar nur
insgesamt zwei prozent des deutschen
außenhandels aus aber bei den direkten
investitionen deutscher unternehmen in
russland sieht es anders aus der
maschinenbau die pharma und
energiebranche warnen schon heute vor
höheren einkaufspreisen hinzu kommt dass
russland deutschland nicht nur öl und
gas liefert und die energiepreise das
beobachten wir seit wochen und monate
steigen sondern auch weitere wichtige
rohstoffe wie zum beispiel aluminium
oder palladium palladium ist zum
beispiel wichtig für die deutsche
autoindustrie gerade noch sprachen
ökonomen nach omikron von einer
entspannung bei den lieferengpässen und
hofften auf eine abflachende
inflationsrate nun sieht seit heute
alles wieder anders aus die karten
werden neu gemischt wieder rohstoff und
lieferengpässe und heute morgen sagt das
institut der deutschen wirtschaft eine
inflation von über 6 prozent voraus das
trifft mit höheren preisen dann
letztlich wieder uns alle neben dem
ganzen leid sehen welche entwicklungen
gibt es denn während der ukraine krise
an der moskauer börse
die moskauer börse sagt massiv ab wie
gesagt handeln muss zwischenzeitlich
eingeschränkt ausgesetzt werden wir
haben es die ganzen wochen und monate
schon gesehen der rubel wird in
mitleidenschaft gezogen die russischen
staatsanleihen
verlieren dementsprechend und diejenigen
unternehmen die natürlich mit russland
jetzt handel führen müssen sich in auf
diese sanktionen einstellen und müssen
auch gucken das weitgehend ihnen die
geschäftsgrundlage wahrscheinlich
entzogen wird oder auf jeden fall eine
andere sein wird je nachdem wie dieser
konflikt sich jetzt weiter entwickelt
welche prognosen entwicklung sind an der
börse denn weiterhin zu befürchten heute
morgen habe ich tatsächlich mit zwei
autonomen gesprochen die gesagt haben
damit haben wir überhaupt nicht
gerechnet das haben wir nicht
eingepreist das ist eine eskalation die
wir hofften dass sie vermieden werden
kann und alles was bis jetzt eine
entspannung an wirtschaftswachstum für
dieses jahr und fürs kommende jahr
vorausgesagt wurde wird jetzt erst
einmal auf null gesetzt also es ist viel
der schöne satz wir dachten eigentlich
wir hätten es jetzt geschafft und
omikron flacht abbilder corona verlauf
durch diese neue variante das wachstum
steigt wieder langsam frühjahrsbelebung
und jetzt durch diesen krieg unter uns
mitten in deutschland können wir alle
prognosen erst einmal auf null setzen
und müssen sehen wie sich sowohl das
wirtschaftswachstum als auch der gesamte
handel entwickelt es muss öl und gas
dieses energieproblem muss irgendwie
gelöst werden energie muss aus dem
ausland wieder zugekauft werden also da
sind noch einige themen die jetzt auf
der agenda sind die heute morgen erst
einmal ganz neu berechnet werden müssen
sina mainitz live von der frankfurter
börse vielen dank
und mein kollege lothar becker ist in
lemberg in der ukraine
lothar wir haben gerade die meldung
erhalten dass es 40 tote gegeben haben
soll was wissen sie
genauere zahlen haben wir hier in
limberg auch nicht ganz sicher auch weil
es im moment für viele wichtiger ist die
gesamtlage im griff zu haben und zu
beobachten wie sich die dinge hier
weiterentwickeln an diesem morgen das
einmarsch der russischen truppen in der
ukraine
ganz sicher kann man im moment nur sagen
dass es in den frühen morgenstunden mit
einem ersten schlag begann da haben
russische vornehmlich raketen
offensichtlich stützpunkte der
ukrainischen streitkräfte angegriffen
ziel war es wohl möglichst schnell die
luftwaffe außer gefecht zu setzen das
scheint so kann man es im moment
vermuten auch gelungen zu sein und
danach traten dann an den grenzen die
ersten meldungen auf bei den mann davon
sprach dass auch bodentruppen mit
schwerem gerät
möglicherweise auch haubitzen
granatwerfern in die ukraine
einmarschiert sind das hat wiederum bei
der bevölkerung in dem im ganzen land
für eine echte verunsicherung gesorgt da
war es auch wenig zu erwarten dass der
aufruf des präsidenten bitte ruhe zu
bewahren zu hause zu bleiben irgendwie
befolgt werden würde die menschen haben
angst um ihr leben im moment sind viele
menschen aus den großen städten
unterwegs hinaus aufs land versuchen
durch verstopfte straßen zu kommen und
das problem bleibt weiterhin dass auch
die infrastruktur an ihre grenzen gerät
nicht nur an den straßen wir sehen hier
in lemberg auch dass eigentlich alle
banken alle geldautomaten
stark belegt sind stark frequentiert
sind es sich lange schlangen bilden und
die menschen versuchen also an geld zu
kommen an kraftstoff zu kommen und sich
irgendwie in sicherheit zu bringen
welche ziele werden denn derzeit vom
russischen militär angegriffen was es
darüber bekannt was hören sie
also im moment stellte sich aus der
einschätzung die wir hier die ich hier
ausländer geben kann stellte sich so dar
dass in allen großen städten berichtet
wurde dass man starke explosionen gehört
habe nicht in den städten aber man hat
also die explosion stattfand nicht in
den städten statt aber sie wurden in den
städten gehört das spricht dafür dass
endlich wie hier in lemberg außen
liegende militärstützpunkte angegriffen
wurden und dass eben verbreitet in der
ganzen ukraine
das ist jetzt eben die frage was machen
die panzer an der grenze rücken sie
weiter vor wenn sie weiter vorrücken
treffen sie früher oder später auch auf
die straßen auf denen viele menschen
derzeit versuchen sich in sicherheit zu
bringen sodass also dieser tag im moment
noch überhaupt nicht absehbar irgendeine
entwicklung prognostizieren lässt die
ersten meldungen von zivilen opfern sind
da wie viele es genau sind weiß man
nicht und man weiß auch bei allen
meldungen die in den vergangenen tagen
kaum auf diese meldungen stimmen ob sie
nicht stimmen das einzige was sicher zu
sein scheint ist das starke
truppenbewegungen im osten der ukraine
am boden stattfinden und dort die
gesamten region luhansk und dort erobert
werden sollen gleichzeitig ukrainische
streitkräfte versuchen durch brücken
sprengungen die russischen truppen
irgendwie aufzuhalten oder zu
verlangsamen und meine damen und herren
kunst der blick zur uhr wir haben 11 uhr
30 und genau für jetzt hat bundeskanzler
scholz eine pressekonferenz im
kanzleramt angekündigt aber wie sie
sehen ist er noch nicht erschienen wir
werden ihnen diese pressekonferenz
selbstverständlich live zeigen deshalb
lothar noch eine frage an dich bis die
pk beginnt was erwartet die ukraine denn
jetzt vom westen
ich habe heute das gefühl dass diese
permanenten forderungen nach aktiver
militärischer unterstützung nach waffen
nach
verteidigungstechnik seitens der
ukrainischen streitkräfte dass das
durchaus begründet war denn man hat
offensichtlich hier in acht jahren krieg
gelernt dass man den ankündigungen aus
moskau in keinster form glauben schenken
kann dass es eben bei der vorstellung es
handelt sich nur um irgendwelche manöver
dass das nicht stimmen könne das hat man
hier in kiew als ich noch ein kind war
gemerkt die politiker waren äußerst
ungehalten wenn sie unterstützung aus
dem ausland bekommen haben die nicht
militärisch war weil sie gesagt haben
die sanktionen werden tod ihn nicht
abhalten und ich gehe davon aus dass
jetzt klarere zeichen eingefordert
werden
präsidentin lenski hat ja eben auch
schon internationale unterstützung für
die sicherheit seines landes für den
luftraum der ukraine eingefordert und so
sieht sich die ukrainische regierung im
moment recht allein dastehen denn was
die ukrainische streit und kraft was die
ukrainischen streitkräfte jetzt nicht zu
leisten imstande sind das wird man
aufgeben müssen das heißt hier ist klar
dieser schnelle angriff heute morgen
führt die ukraine an ihre grenzen und
noch ist unklar ob sie überhaupt in der
lage sein werden diesen geplanten
vormarsch der russischen truppen in
irgendeiner form so aufzuhalten dass sie
selber herr der lage bleiben sodass also
nun die internationale reaktion hier in
der ukraine mit ganz besondere hoffnung
aufgenommen wird so sie denn kommt
lothar becker vielen dank bis hierhin
und meine damen und herren wir warten
aktuell auf ein statement von
bundeskanzler scholz aus dem
bundeskanzleramt und das halten wir
jetzt noch mal nach berlin zum meinem
kollegen thomas reichert was ist denn da
zu erwarten
naja diese sicherheitskabinett das im
moment im bundeskanzleramt arg das ist
ein gremium das nicht regelmäßig
zusammenkommen so nur in besonderen
situationen es kam zuletzt zusammen am
dienstag nachdem wladimir putin
die separatisten republiken anerkannt
hat und man erste truppenbewegungen
erkennen konnte und es tat leben jetzt
seit zehn uhr
dabei wird es vermutlich um eine
abgestimmte reaktion gehen es geht um
mögliche flüchtlingsbewegungen es wird
vermutlich auch darum gehen die die
sanktionen jetzt umgesetzt werden und
die insgesamt auch die situation der
noch in der ukraine befindlichen
deutschen eingeschätzt wird die
außenministerin annalena baerbock hat
heute morgen in einem dramatischen
appell die deutschen aufgefordert
dringend das land zu verlassen hat
gleichzeitig auch diese
völkerrechtswidrigen angriff da die mir
putins aufs schärfste verurteilt wir
haben gerade im bild gesehen das ist der
große saal im bundeskanzleramt mit den
insignien für den g 7 gipfel oder
verrieten gremium deutschland hat da den
vorsitz und auch heute nachmittag wird
es da einen virtuellen gipfel der g 7
unter deutschem vorsitz unter vorsitz
von bundeskanzler olaf scholz geben auch
da wird es natürlich um eine abgestimmte
reaktion des westens auf russlands
invasion in der ukraine gehen aber
allein die tatsache dass dieses dass
kanzler scholz noch nicht wie
angekündigt jetzt um 11.30 vor die
presse getreten ist lässt schon mal
erahnen dass es in diesem
sicherheitskabinett viel zu besprechen
gibt wie gesagt darin vertreten sind die
außenministerin die innenministerin
verteidigungsministerin also sozusagen
die sicherheitsorgane der
bundesregierung außerdem die dienste das
bundesamt für verfassungsschutz
bundesnachrichtendienst und auch das
bundeskriminalamt ist sozusagen die
sicherheitsorgane deutschland die sich
dafür die innere wie auch für die äußere
sicherheit befassen gibt heute sicher
viel zu besprechen deswegen dauert es im
moment noch etwas
darüber sprechen welche möglichkeiten
bundeskanzler scholz in solch einer lage
überhaupt hat sie haben gesagt er kann
sich abstimmen er kann sich absprechen
aber die bisherigen sanktionen in
richtung moskau in richtung putin die
haben ja nicht die gewünschte wirkung
bisher erzielt etwas rechnet man dann
jetzt
also gerechnet wird natürlich jetzt mit
besonders scharfen
sanktionen das hat die außenministerin
hat annalena baerbock heute früh schon
angekündigt das sind möglicherweise
sanktionen die den finanzsektor
russlands betreffen harte sanktionen
gegen große banken russlands die ist die
ausland sozusagen ich es essentiell vom
internationalen zahlungsverkehr
abschneiden sollen es soll auch
sanktionen geben natürlich gegen
individuen das haben wir am dienstag
bereits gesehen dass der abgeordnete der
duma sanktioniert wurden das wird sich
vermutlich ausweiten wichtige frage wird
sein ob auch vladimir putin persönlich
teil dieser sanktion sein wird also
insgesamt 1 ein scharfes schwert an
sanktionen aber natürlich muss man
andererseits sagen
was jetzt zutage tritt ist ein kühl ein
geplanter angriff von dem man ausgehen
muss dass putin natürlich auch die
sanktion damit eingepreist hat zu hören
ist dass er vorsorge geleistet hat und
dass verschiedene institute und experten
davon ausgehen dass hat für mehrere
monate möglicherweise solche sanktionen
aushalten kann trotzdem so wie sie
geplant sind zudem von dem was man
bislang über sie gehört hat werden sie
schmerzhaft sein zumindest mittelfristig
für russland das in extremer weise von
seinen rohstoff exporten abhängig ist
aber noch mal die geschichte der
sanktionen in den internationalen
beziehungen sei es nordkorea sei es der
iran ist keine die nun sozusagen da zu
großen hoffnungen anlass gibt zumindest
was sozusagen kurzfristige reaktionen
angibt die tatsache dass heute
nachmittag noch mal schärfere sanktionen
abgestimmt mit der eu mit dem westen mit
den usa verkündet werden mit putin
sicher nicht sofort zum umkehren
verleiten thomas reichert vielen dank
nach berlin und meine damen und herren b
gehen live nach moskau um wieder zu
meinem kollegen christian sen
christian behrens gehört das werden noch
schärfere sanktionen auf russland zu
kommen wie reagierten russische
präsident darauf
thomas reichert gerade angesprochen wir
können davon ausgehen dass die
vorkehrungen getroffen worden und wurden
und aktuell gibt es jetzt noch keine
reaktion darauf auch sozusagen auf diese
ganze militärische aktion putin hat das
heute morgen hier im staatsfernsehen
verkündet in einem halbstündigen monolog
und jetzt aber sozusagen die reaktion
auf diese ereignisse die steht noch aus
putin hat heute noch weitere termine
wird sich mit dem pakistanischen
ministerpräsidenten
premierminister treffen vielleicht wird
es dann nochmal eine äußerungen geben
ansonsten gibt es dann eine äußerung aus
der staatsduma der vorsitzende
staatsduma wolodin hat sich geäußert und
hat versucht nochmal die russische
intention zu claire erklären und was
auffällt man will sich hier nicht als
aggressor präsentieren sondern man
versuchte im ukrainischen volk klar zu
machen dass man ist sozusagen befreien
will von den fängen der neonazis von den
fängen einer einer falschen regierung
ich kann das mal zitieren wolodin sagt
ich appelliere an die bürger der ukraine
wir haben sie als brüderliches volk
betrachtet so betrachten wir sie immer
noch die aktion unseres landes zielen
ausschließlich auf den schutz des
friedens ab wir bitten sie sich nicht
einzumischen und nicht an
mobilisierungen teilzunehmen die von den
kieler behörden vorgeschlagen werden sie
sind nicht unabhängig alle befehle
werden von washington und brüssel
erteilt und das ist der tenor den wir
schon ganz lange hören auch hier in der
propaganda auch im staatsfernsehen wo
immer wieder versucht wurde zu zeigen
dass die ukraine ein fremdgesteuert
ukrainischer startet fremdgesteuerten
start ist wenn wir das uns anhören womit
müssen wir denn da rechnen womit muss
die welt rechnen was hat wladimir putin
denn dann noch vor viele befürchten jahr
nach der ukraine hört es nicht auf
ja wir haben in den letzten wochen und
monaten über verschiedene szenarien
gesprochen da war vieles denkbar das was
heute passiert das war ja auch eines der
szenarien da sind die die kühnsten
albträume sind ja sozusagen wahr
geworden insofern ist jetzt glaube ich
sozusagen die vorstellungskraft offen in
welche richtung das gehen putin hat auch
ganz konkret
gewarnt nach dem eingreifen jetzt in der
ukraine
ist er sich natürlich auch nicht sicher
wie die reaktion der ukrainischen
streitkräfte sein kann da hat er an die
soldaten appelliert und er ist sich auch
nicht sicher wie vielleicht die reaktion
anderer länder sein wird aber da schickt
er voraus das kann ich auch noch mal
zitieren aus seiner ansprache heute
morgen im staatsfernsehen
wer auch immer versucht uns zu behindern
und noch mehr bedrohung für unser volk
zu schaffen der sollte wissen dass die
reaktion russlands sofort erfolgen wird
und solche konsequenzen haben wird wie
man sie in der geschichte noch nie
erlebt hat also das ist eine klare
kampfansage
der westen hat er vorgehen russland
scharf verurteilt welche unterstützer
hat russland dann überhaupt noch
mehr vor allem den belarussischen
diktator lukaschenko russland und
belarus haben in diesen gemeinsamen
unionsstaaten sie sind in der
vergangenheit ja auch so zu sagen ja
fast schon
repräsentativ brüderlich aufgetreten um
zu zeigen zwischen uns passt kein blatt
wir erinnern uns diktator lukaschenko
war nach den gefälschten wahlen in
belarus sehr unter druck konnte
sozusagen nur überleben durch die
unterstützung russlands
und jetzt unterstützt er auch wladimir
putin das gab das groß angelegte
gemeinsame militärmanöver in belarus was
ihr an der zusätzliche bedrohung für die
ukraine war wo beide seiten immer
beschwichtigt haben also lukaschenko und
putin und gesagt haben erstmals können
wir auf unserem territorium machen was
wir wollen und das ist lediglich eine
übung und nach der übung werden die
soldaten zurückkehren jetzt wissen wir
auch das ist nicht passiert und lukas
schinko fühlt sich natürlich
gewissermaßen in der pflicht für
russland und für wladimir putin weil er
einfach abhängig ist von ihm und hat
jetzt heute ganz aktuell auch noch mal
seine unterstützung angeboten
christian eine letzte frage noch wie
reagiert denn die russische bevölkerung
auf das was da gerade in der ukraine
passiert und wie hier berichten die
medien
also im staatsfernsehen liefert morgen
die besagte rede jetzt wird eben über
diesen diesen konflikt auch berichtet
wie genau im detail konnte ich mir jetzt
persönlich noch nicht angucken dazu wird
gleich nochmal zeit sein im vorfeld
haben die menschen hier sehr
unterschiedlich reagiert auf diesen
drohenden konflikt manche folgen dieser
staatspropaganda und sehen auch die
ukraine als sozusagen gefallenen staat
ansehen die schuldigen dafür aber eher
im westen also in den usa und in europa
andere haben immer uns vorhergesagt bei
straßenumfragen einen krieg mit unserem
bruder folgt sozusagen das können wir
uns nicht vorstellen man darf nicht
vergessen viele haben noch familiäre
bindungen in die ukraine
viele ukraine
kommen auch oder sind der vergangenheit
oft nach nach russland gekommen
umgekehrter gab es gab es viel austausch
bis zu den zu den stücken zuspitzungen
auch bis auch zur annexion der krim 2015
da fehlt dann fehlten viele vielen
wirklich die vorstellungskraft jetzt
sind von einer oppositionspolitikerin
proteste ausgerufen worden wie groß die
werden können wird man sehen müssen
auch wie stark dieser aufruf sein können
denn eines dürfen wir auch nicht
vergessen in den letzten monaten und im
letzten jahr haben wir hier ein massives
vorgehen eine massive repressionswelle
gegen die opposition erfahren insofern
fehlen jetzt im moment in russland auch
die großen köpfe die eine gegenposition
zu dem einnehmen könnte was vladimir
putin da gerade macht vielen dank
christian selber und meine damen und
herren wir warten immer noch auf das
statement von bundeskanzler stolz denn
natürlich ist auch die politik in berlin
von den entwicklungen in der ukraine
aufs höchste alarmiert sie sehen hier
live bilder aus dem bundeskanzleramt
aber der kanzler ist noch nicht
erschienen wir zeigen ihnen die
pressekonferenz selbstverständlich live
deutsche staatsbürger wurden dringend
aufgerufen das land möglichst schnell zu
verlassen außenministerin der bank
kündigte nach einer sitzung des
krisenstabs im auswärtigen amt schärfste
sanktionen an bundesinnenministerium
feser twitterte zu auswirkungen dieses
russischen angriffskriege auf die
sicherheitslage in deutschland und auf
fluchtbewegungen in europa sind wir
äußerst wachsam und vorbereitet die
sicherheitsbehörden haben sich auf alle
szenarien vorbereitet und
schutzmaßnahmen hochgefahren so nancy
faeser am vormittag berät das
sicherheitskabinett der bundesregierung
im kanzleramt
in berlin tagt 10 uhr das
sicherheitskabinett kurz zuvor tritt die
aussenministerin noch vor die presse
dieser krieg soll vor allem eins
zerstören die hoffnung der menschen in
der ukraine
dass sie nach jahrzehnten der unfreiheit
ein recht auf demokratie ein recht auf
frieden und auf eine bessere zukunft
ohne unterdrückung haben
präsident putin diesen traum werden sie
niemals zerstören können er wächst in
der ukraine
er wächst genau so in ihrem land auch
die deutsche verteidigungsministerin
wendet sich heute direkt an den
russischen präsidenten putin tritt
völkerrecht mit füßen und nimmt
unfassbares leid in auch in kauf um
seine großmacht fantasien zu befriedigen
das muss ein ende haben wir müssen
geschlossen stehen in der nato in der eu
und jetzt muss es ganz schnell wirksame
konsequente sanktionen geben es muss
klar sein herr putin die nato die eu
stehen geschlossen zusammen wir stehen
zu unseren verbündeten ziehen sie ihre
truppen zurück sofort die diplomatischen
bemühungen die sanktionsdrohung der
letzten wochen vergeblich vizekanzler
harbeck spricht von einem angriffskrieg
auf ein souveränes land und zeigt sich
selbstkritisch aber
diese aktionen waren eigentlich dazu
gedacht ist nicht zum krieg kommen zu
lassen und es war ein drohpotenzial von
dem putin ahnen konnte dass es hart
werden wird und das wird es auch werden
aber es hätte natürlich nicht vom krieg
abgehalten rückblickend muss man sagen
wenn man sich die schriften von putin
aus dem letzten sommer anschaut wenn man
die wort und wir unterbrechen an dieser
stelle und gehen jetzt live nach berlin
denn der bundeskanzler olaf scholz
beginnt jetzt eine pressekonferenz für
tag für europa
mit seinem angriff auf die ukraine
bricht der russische präsident putin
abermals eklatant das völkerrecht
putin bringt damit leid und zerstörung
über seine direkten nachbarn
er verletzt die souveränität und die
grenzen der ukraine
er gefährdet das leben von unzähligen
unschuldigen in der ukraine dem bruder
volk russlands
letzlich stellte damit auch die
friedensordnung unseres kontinents in
fragen für all das gibt es keine
rechtfertigung das ist putins krieg
ich habe dem ukrainischen präsidenten
selensky heute früh in einem telefonat
gesagt in diesen schweren stunden gilt
die ukraine
und gilt ihr und ihren bürgerinnen und
bürgern unsere volle solidarität
angesichts der aktuellen entwicklung
habe ich heute vormittag das
sicherheitskabinett einberufen damit die
regierung über die lage beraten und über
das weitere vorgehen gemeinsam
entscheidet
alle bundesbürger die noch im land sind
bitte ich abermals sehr dringt die
ukraine zu verlassen zu ihrem eigenen
schutz
die präsidentin des deutschen
bundestages habe ich gebeten für sonntag
eine sondersitzung des bundestages 1
berufen dort werde ich eine
regierungserklärung abgeben
als vorsitzender der g7 werde ich mich
heute nachmittag in einer
video-konferenz der g7 staats und
regierungschefs für eine einheitliche
und klare reaktion der wirtschaftlich
stärksten demokratien der welt einsetzen
als nächsten schritt werden wir in enger
absprache mit unseren internationalen
partnern in der nato und in der
europäischen union noch heute weitere
harte sanktionen gegen russland
beschließen es ist gut dass wir das
sorgfältig vorbereitet haben
ziel der sanktionen ist es der
russischen führung klar zu machen für
diese aggression teilt sie einen
bitteren preis
es wird sich zeigen
putin hat mit seinem krieg einen
schweren fehler begangen
lassen sie mich noch ein wort an unseren
nato-verbündeten in osteuropa in polen
rumänien im baltikum richten ich möchte
ihnen ausdrücklich versichern wir
verstehen eure sorgen im angesicht
dieser entwicklung nur zu gut wir werden
euch zur seite stehen deutschland steht
zur beistandspflicht der nato
gemeinsam mit dem französischen
präsidenten schlage ich vor dass sich
die staats und regierungschefs der nato
staaten sehr bald in präsenz treffen um
die lage zu erörtern
heute abend werde ich nach brüssel
fahren um dort im kreise der staats und
regierungschefs der europäischen union
das weitere vorgehen zu besprechen
die lage ist sehr ernst
russlands präsidenten putin möchte ich
dazu aufrufen den militärischen angriff
sofort zu stoppen
dem blutvergießen
einhalt zu gebieten und seine truppen
vom territorium der ukraine vollständig
zurück zu ziehen
vielen dank
von olaf scholz live aus dem
bundeskanzleramt
nachfragen von journalisten gab ist
nicht wurde vermutlich gar nicht
zugelassen
er hat sich recht kurz gehalten aber war
doch sehr deutlich wir fragen jetzt mal
live nach bei meinem kollegen thomas
reichert in berlin thomas wie ist dieses
erste statement von olaf scholz
einzuordnen
also das war ein sehr ernster
sehr gewichtige statement von von olaf
scholz hat im grunde die punkte klar
gemacht die zu erwarten sind aber in
einer deutlichkeit wie sie in einer
solchen situation vermutlich auch nötig
sind er hat angekündigt dass es für
sanktionen geben wird er hat ebenfalls
angekündigt dass er gemeinsam mit
frankreichs präsident marco sich
einsetzen wird sein treffen in person
der nato staats und regierungschefs und
er hat etwas sehr wichtiges gemacht er
hat ein signal eine botschaft gesendet
an die osteuropäischen nato staaten und
ihnen versichert dass deutschland in
ihrer seite stehe das ist ein bezug auf
artikel 5 ein angriff auf eines dieser
länder ist ein angriff auf alle also die
solidarität ist in dieser situation
sicher etwas sehr wichtiges
er hat die gleiche solidarität
allerdings eben nicht mit militärischen
beistand ausgesprochen gegenüber der
ukraine
und er hat wladimir putin aufgefordert
die truppen zurückzuziehen das ist in
der aktuellen situation eine wichtige
forderung aber es ist vermutlich ein auf
die putin nicht hören wird ich glaube
die botschaft die wir heute jetzt da von
bundeskanzler olaf scholz gesehen und
gehört haben ist die von einer
entschlossenen reaktion des westens der
sehr darauf achte dass er sozusagen darf
in dieser existenziellen krise
zusammensteht und auch diejenigen die
besonders bedroht sind das sind in
diesem fall auch die osteuropäischen
staaten neben natürlich der ukraine dass
er denen die solidarität und den
beistand versichert
bundeskanzler scholz hat gesagt für die
russischen aktionen muss russland einen
hohen preis bezahlen das sei das ziel
der funktionen und er hat weitere harte
sanktionen angekündigt wie schnell muss
wie schnell wird david passieren ich
glaube das wird sehr schnell passieren
denn diese sanktion sind ja seit wochen
im detail vorbereitet worden nicht nur
von deutschland sondern eben in
verbunden mit den europäischen staaten
mit den westen mit den usa kanada und
großbritannien insofern ist relativ klar
glaube ich was jetzt da passieren wird
olaf scholz hat angekündigt dass am
abend nach brüssel fahren wird
spätestens zu diesem zeitpunkt wird dann
von wirklich auch klar welche sanktionen
es konkret sind sie sollen und sie
müssen ja auch russland schmerzen auch
wenn wir davon ausgehen müssen dass
wladimir putin bei seinem kühl
kalkulierten angriffskrieg auch diese
sanktion erstmal mit eingepreist hat
dafür sie werden natürlich ihre wirkung
entfalten
insofern als banken betroffen werden
russland wahrscheinlich weitgehend vom
internationalen zahlungsverkehr
abgeschnitten werden soll
rohstoffexporte eingeschränkt werden und
auch unternehmen betroffen werden
interessant wird zu sehen sein ob ist
eine ausweitung persönlicher sanktionen
gegen vertreter russlands gibt und ob
dabei auch über die mir putin selbst mit
eingeschlossen ist es kann sein dass man
vielleicht da sich noch eine letzte
eskalationsstufe offen lässt in der
hoffnung dass putin vielleicht doch noch
zum verhandlungstisch zurückkehrt das
wird werden wir sehen in der summe ist
klar es wird scharfe sanktionen geben
und sie sind im grunde schon vorbereitet
sie müssen jetzt von den staats und
regierungschefs nur noch verabschiedet
werden thomas reichert nach dem
statement des bundeskanzlers ja meine
damen und herren das ist also geschehen
von dem alle gehofft hatten dass es
nicht eintreten würde russland hat einen
großangriff auf die ukraine gestartet in
kiew und anderen städten waren
explosionen zu hören auch russische
bodentruppen sollen aus verschiedenen
richtungen in das land vorrücken nach
angaben der ukrainischen regierung sind
bislang mehr als 40 soldaten getötet
worden außerdem etwa zehn zivilisten
karen ort fasst zusammen
absperrband um die reste einer rakete in
einer straße von kiew am frühen morgen
war sie hier eingeschlagen die anwohner
immer noch fassungslos
ich wohne gleich da drüben es war eine
unglaublich starke explosion ich hatte
panik und rannte nach draußen
überall sirenen und die alarmanlagen der
autos greifen
in der nacht hatte präsident putin aus
drohungen und ankündigungen fakten
gemacht bilder aus hartz iv sollen erste
angriffe zeigen notwendige angriffe so
sieht es putin ich habe die entscheidung
für eine militär operation getroffen um
menschen zu schützen die seit acht
jahren einem völkermord durch das regime
in kiew ausgesetzt waren bis zum ende
streben wir eine entmilitarisierung und
entnazifizierung der ukraine an außerdem
werden wir die zur rechenschaft ziehen
die verbrechen an der zivilbevölkerung
begangen haben nach und nach gibt es
immer mehr bilder der angriffe diese
sollen dem militärflughafen in coburg
zeigen russland behauptet diesen
zerstört zu haben ähnliche bilder auch
vom flughafen in mario pohl der
hafenstadt am schwarzen meer auch die
stadt selbst soll angegriffen worden
sein als reaktion verhängte der
ukrainische präsident selensky das
kriegsrecht in einer videobotschaft rief
er seine landsleute dazu auf nicht in
panik zu verfallen wir sind stark und
auf alles vorbereitet wir werden siegen
der ukrainische botschafter in
deutschland warnt und bittet im
morgenmagazin des zdf
es ist jetzt an der zeit uns zur seite
zu stellen wenn die ukraine fällt dann
ist europa als nächstes opfer dabei dass
das muss man so leider sehen und
deswegen wir brauchen auch jetzt
unterstützung für die verteidigung um
die menschen zu schützen denn die
ukrainische armee ist zwar bereit aber
aber wir sind natürlich da nach wie vor
in einer position wo wir auf einem sehr
sehr mächtigen gegner stehen auch diese
ukrainische militärstützpunkt soll ziel
von raketen geworden sein ein soldat
fordert die menschen auf die gegend zu
verlassen
sie können jederzeit wieder zuschlagen
sie müssen sofort weg hier
genau das versuchen viele bilder aus
kiew zeigen lange staus raus aus der
stadt nur wohin ist die frage
die nato geht angesichts der aktuellen
entwicklungen in den krisenmodus und hat
angekündigt ihre luft land und
seestreitkräfte im osten zu verstärken
alle maßnahmen seien und blieben aber
präventiv und nicht eskalierend so heißt
es in einer erklärung der 30
bündnisstaaten und mir live zugeschaltet
ist jetzt nochmal egon ramms ehemalige
nato-general wie schätzen sie das ein
also die schütze das wo ein dass die
nato bei der verstärkung an der
ostflanke sich weiter betätigen wird mit
truppen sollen die verfügbar sind wir
haben in diesem bereich noch nicht
getroffen noch nicht gesprochen über die
sogenannte very high point task force
über die nato verfügt und die jedes jahr
in der rotation neu aufgestellt wird
entsprechend vorbereitet wird diese ist
bisher noch nicht betroffen von
irgendwelchen alarmierungs maßnahmen
steht also noch zur verfügung und könnte
jederzeit auch auf relativ kurzer zeit
achse in die osteuropäischen nato
staaten verlegen er hat angriffe gibt es
nicht nur aus der luft sondern auch
bodentruppen sollen einmarschiert sein
wie schnell kann das jetzt gehen
inwiefern rechnen sie mit nennenswerten
widerstand gegen die russischen boden
gruppen
also ich rechne mit widerstand der
ukrainischen armee war die ukrainische
armee sei 2014
den ausbildungsstand auch ihrer moral
ihrer kampfkraft deutlich verbessert
worden ist von daher glaube ich nicht
dass das ein russischer durchmarsch
werden wird allerdings bleibt abzuwarten
wie sich die luftangriffe die heute
nacht stattgefunden haben auf den
zustand der armee ausgewirkt haben das
ist im augenblick noch ein bisschen
schwer zu beurteilen herr general ihre
einschätzung zum schluss ist das eine
zäsur
wie wird sich die bundeswehr die nato
künftig aufstellen müssen
also es ist eine zäsur insgesamt für die
europäische friedensordnung die 175 mit
dem ksc prozess begonnen hat über die
osze fortgesetzt worden ist und wo ist
hier auch in den zeiten der 90er jahre
verschiedenste erklärung gegeben hat mit
denen russland damals die sicherheit und
unverletzlichkeit der grenzen auch der
ukraine garantiert hat und ich möchte
noch mal daran erinnern dass die ukraine
ja unter diesen gesichtspunkten auch auf
die nuklear waffen die auf ihrem boden
stationiert waren verzichtet hat das
heißt die gesamte friedensordnung die
sich auf verträge auf abkommen auf
memoranden und dergleichen abgestürzt
ist damit von putin ad acta gelegt
worden und wir müssen sehen wie sich das
ganze weiter entwickelt und ob man dann
wenn er die ukraine komplett eingenommen
haben sollte ich betone den konjunktiv
dabei ob er sich dann wieder an den
verhandlungstisch setzt man vielleicht
dann wieder eine neue europäische
friedensordnung auf der basis von
abkommen zustande bekommt aber ich
möchte darauf hinweisen dass ein mann
wie putin der dieses in dieser art und
weise gemacht hat
wahrscheinlich mit solchen verhandlungen
und solchen dingen nicht mehr den tisch
zurückkehrt sagt und warnt egon ramms
ehemalige nato-general vielen dank ja
meine damen und herren so viel für den
moment hier geht es jetzt weiter mit den
nachrichten und gundula gause und direkt
danach ein weiteres zdf spezial zum
krieg in der ukraine
wir informieren sie darüber hinaus über
alle aktuellen entwicklungen online auf